Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Hast du schon gehört die haben Alex Jones zensiert.
Was das haben mit schwulen Frösche aus der Spree auch schon erzählt.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 264 mal wieder live aus der Metaebene.
Das wirklich die 264 wirklich ich will mir nicht so sicher aber ja wird schon sein live aus der Beta Ebene aufgezeichnet.
Ja also ja wir haben wir haben unsere Urlaub und sonstigen Ausflüge jetzt ausreichend effizient.
Dienstreisen Teens.
Dienstreisen unterbrochen unterbrechen den Urlaub für dieses kurze Programm noch einiges.
Ja mein Kopfhörer ist uns auch ein bisschen leise hier ist alles verstellt.
Mein Kopfhörer ist leise so und dann kann man noch dran arbeiten.
Ok bei Eier jetzt so ist gut Motor Motorfader hier.
Wird langsam warm ja wir müssen wir müssen uns hier erstmal wieder ein Gruben öffnen hin habe ich gesagt dass es die 204/16 ist habe ich gesagt aber ich habe noch nicht gesagt genau 10. August 2018 ist heute.
Und ja ihr lauscht unserem Programm und was nicht war was irgendwas das war ja viel in der Luft.
Wasserscheid auch noch einiges zu sein ja.
Also ich kann jetzt auch noch keinen Urlaub Resümee ziehen weil so richtig fertig bin ich ja damit noch nicht ich bin es ja eigentlich eher so zwischendurch mal wieder aufgeschlagen und mich neue zu sammeln.
Das ist super Tim aber ich esse ich vergesse ich höre ja diese,
diese Privatleben résumés in manchen Podcast dann auch ne das ist jedesmal als Wände irgendeiner von seinem acid Trip erzählt das war sicherlich faszinierend,
ist aber jetzt echt gerade nicht interessant.
Bitte dass ich wollte auch nicht damit an.
Insofern wäre es ja eh gerade eine Stunde das sollte jetzt nicht wenn du für ein Podcast der uns ja schon über dein Podcast über den Urlaub unterhalten Podcast,
ein Gentleman genießt und schweigt.
Genau ja das habe ich auch getan und werde auch noch weiter tun dazu komme auch am Ende noch mal ja ansonsten.
Petek hatten wir.
Hatten wir Feedback wieder so einiges und da wollen wir doch mal auf das ein oder andere auch eingeben.
Das Wichtigste Feedback war eigentlich also die war es gab doch mal aufhören Hashtag was da gemacht wurde für das engage ment was ihr seht wenn ihr Podcasts hört.
Wissen will wie der was ich sehe wenn ich einen Podcast irgendwie abspiele höre.
Irgend so ein Klick Kampagne hatte nicht ganz den Erfolg von metoo aber war auch war auch eine nette Idee.
So aber der geht jetzt ein Gewinner der Gewinner ist selbstverständlich erstens LocoNet wird sich als der Podcast der gehört wurde und dann in der Gewinner ist Tobi.
Denn Tobi hat die Daten Elch Folge auf einer elchfarm in Schweden gehört und hatte und hat die Folge über LTE gehört.
Die Folge welt.de gehört offener elchfarm in.
Da war alles voll mit Daten keine Empfangsprobleme.
Es war mitten in der tobi hat gewonnen hat gewonnen.
Gratuliere Tobi besser geht's nicht.
Ich traue mich gleich zur nächsten Feedback zukommen Tim weil wenn wir jetzt jede Woche also irgendwie müssen wir dieses Thema öffentlichen Rundfunk auch wieder abschließen ne.
Ich glaube auch geht hier irgendwie passt weniger um das Thema selbst als schon fast mir so eine Meta.
Mittag mit der Behandlung von Kommentaren an sich weiß ich noch nicht so ganz genau worauf genau so was was war geschehen wie haben es in der letzten Sendung über öffentlichen Rundfunk unterhalten.
Dinge in der vorletzten.
Vorletzten Wagen vor der Zusendung und liegt noch hier eine Hitze ja da haben wir einiges zugesagt.
Da gab's an unter anderem diesen Kommentar Dimitri er schrieb.
Als Ergänzung und antwortet zu euren Aussagen.
Erstens nicht jeder von uns also offensichtlich handelt es sich hierbei um einen Mitarbeiter des öffentlichen Rundfunks.
Kann sein ja.
Ja also macht so den Eindruck
Ikea von uns bekommt eine Pension die Iris im Podcast gemeint habt was ihr bitte so gesagt haben während ein normaler Arbeitnehmer eine Rente bekommt bekommen die Intendanten und andere Mitarbeiter
Rundfunkräte cetera zusätzlich zur Rente eine Pension und es kann nicht sein dass das meiste Geld dafür
Tierpension Zahlung benutzt wird dann wurde noch auf und ein Video verlinkt was angeblich irgendwas belegen soll es sind aber mittlerweile vom Benutzer gelöscht worden von da konnten wir diese Aussage jetzt nicht weiter,
Drift ziehen.
Aber wir haben eine wenn bisschen dazu recherchiert der Westen schrieb irgendwie sowas wie allein 2017 bis 21 müssen ARD und ZDF
23431 Pensionäre für diese 21 24431 Pensionäre 3,3 Milliarden
Euro aufbringen dass ich zum einen daran dass laut Tarifverträgen die Altersbezüge im selben Maß wie die Bezüge der Mitarbeiter bei den Sendern steigen zurzeit etwa der WDR die größte Anstalt der ARD schon 2014 rund 205 Millionen Euro.
Und seine Rentner und Rentnerin jetzt ist in diesem Artikel wird auch gemischt zwischen Pensionen und Rentenansprüchen offenbar aber ja
da steht also was dran.
Ja gut aber wollt ihr auch dazu dass man Mitarbeiter auch sozusagen über die arbeit hinaus mit bedient sowie das Jahr an anderen.
Naja das hätten Renten Rente und Pension ist das tatsächlich ein bisschen unterschiedlich ne also Rentenkasse kann man ja machen Pension ist.
Wenn das lied aus der laufenden Gebühren bezahlt wird und so viel ist das deswegen die Gebühren nicht sinken können ist schon ein bisschen.
Nur die eigentliche Frage ist sind die Pension als solche angemessen sorgt das kann ich jetzt nicht beurteilen ja.
Und das ist ja offenbar nicht und hier wird ja auch angemerkt dass sie nicht nicht gleichermaßen verteilt sind.
Gut virements,
zweite Anmerkung von Dmitri ihr sagt das in diesen Ämtern solche hohen Gehälter gezahlt werden damit die Leute nicht korrupt werden das höchste Amt in Deutschland ist ja wohl dass der Bundeskanzlerin wie kommt es denn dass,
Tom Buhrow mehr verdient als die Bundeskanzler.
Also Tagesschausprecher ist kein Amt und Tom Buhrow nicht verbeamtet.
Ja und außerdem Bundeskanzlerin nicht das höchste Amt in Deutschland zuerst das dritthöchste Amt in Deutschland muss man auch mal sagen
davon abgesehen ich meine das ist jetzt irgendwie damit kann jetzt alles vergleichen also Bundeskanzler ist jetzt.
Ich erweise für die Position nicht des Geldes wegen angestrebt das ist vielleicht auch ganz gut so.
Ob das die Bundeskanzlerin angemessen bezahlt wird kann ich ehrlich gesagt nicht beurteilen.
Vieles ist sicherlich jetzt nicht wenn man das jetzt mit Spitzenpositionen der freien Wirtschaft vergleicht aber man kann jetzt hier auch nicht Apple und Birnen rausziehen und daraus irgendeiner Aussage über.
Es ist ziemlich also also die die Vergleiche irgendwie Gehälter vergleiche über Bronson hinweg ist eine sehr,
der kann man immer
die die die bittere Ungerechtigkeit der Gesellschaft zahlen ja so kurzer Bezugspflege Debatte gerade in Deutschland nicht wir zuviel gebraucht für Leute in der Pflege niemand wird so schlecht bezahlt ja gehst du woanders hin irgendwie Bereich.
IT security ne werden
in wenn wahrscheinlich auch noch ein paar Leute gebraucht da hat das eine Zahl eine hohe Zahlung zufolge ist das gerecht nein in keiner Weise SODI aber diese Vergleiche kann man kann man.
Mall in innen über alle möglichen Bronson und Tätigkeitsfelder machen und ja,
dazu gibt es unendliche Ungerechtigkeiten und Unmöglichkeiten in in in unserer Gesellschaft.
Da müsste man auch mal was dran machen.
Das ist völlig richtig.
Aber das ist meiner Meinung nach sagt es wie dich über öffentlichen rund.
Der vierte Punkt ist aber tatsächlich einsichtigen.
Guten III geblieben der war.
Der war so lange rausgenommen.
A4 wenn alle Behörden das Geld einfach nur so zum Fenster hinauswerfen dann ist es ein Systemfehler,
da kann man nicht einfach von den Medien auf andere zeigen und argumentieren dass es alle machen,
dann muss man da was ändern dann schickt man für ARD und ZDF einen aus Reporter inklusive Krug aus und nicht zwei jeder in der freien Wirtschaft muss Geld sparen können das müssen die ÖR Medien auch lernen.
Da denke ich auf jeden Fall das dann. Ist in,
aber das glaube ich hatten wir auch eine letzten Sendung angesprochene wenn du wenn du Menschen
mitten wenn du Organisation mit ihm die mehr oder weniger garantierten Budgets aus startest und die nicht einem Sparzwang runter ziehst
dann werden die früher oder später relativ verschwenderisch und leisten sich durchaus einen Überfluss der nicht immer zielführend ist ne also das ist.
Glaube ich einfach. Ist eine Frage der weiß ob dass sie Systemfehler ist oder Organisation infolgedessen wie man Dinge organisiert aber auf jeden Fall geb
gibt es eine BBC die mit sehr viel weniger Geld wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe sehr viel größere
Qualität liefert dem. Muss man einfach denke ich so geben.
Objektivreihe Wirtschaft auch unbedingt immer das beste Beispiel für Geld sparen ist da bin ich mir nicht so sicher wenn ich mir so die Effizienz von Großkonzernen anschauen jeder dir da irgendwann mal einen Job hatte und mal ein paar Wochen sind die
böses Kredit eten reingeschaut er fragt sich eigentlich auch nur wie die überhaupt Geld verdienen.
Das frage ich mich sehr häufig bei Unternehmen also nicht bei denen die jetzt gerade zu hören und bei denen ich zufällig gerade arbeite,
aber es ist tatsächlich.
Verhalten anderer.
Wenn eine wenn eine also das ist tatsächlich sehr interessant in gewissen Organisationsgrad wie wie schnell.
DATEV e Ineffizienz reinkommt ist sehr interessant zu beobachten wenn man in vielen Unternehmen tätig ist aber,
wenn man sich über die sich mal die die Game die Gehälter Ungerechtigkeit zwischen Tom Buhrow und der Bundeskanzlerin ärgert ja,
dann sollte man nicht jetzt sage ich mal in so ein Unternehmen wie Deutsche Telekom oder sonstiges Gehen der wo dir zwischen
einfachen Mitarbeitenden oder oder muss jetzt nicht die Deutsche Telekom and irgendwie spezifisch rausnehme ich weiß nur dass Tim Höttges da jetzt letztens auch an dieser Debatte genannt wurde,
wenn jetzt in in erfolgreiches börsennotiertes Unternehmen gehst dann hast du aber ganz andere Gehälter Unterschiede als die zwischen Angela Merkel und Tom Buhrow.
Naja also die Paket aus Fahrer und die Manager Ebene dass die brennende Welt.
Da ist hoffentlich Schwert wird das dann schwer zu verargumentieren ja und üblicherweise wird dann gesagt ja ich aber hier als CEO ich komme ich ich muss ja,
ich könnte jetzt einem anderen Unternehmen gehen und ich bin eben hier in einer anderen Klasse oder Kaste in der ich kompetitiv.
Bezahlt werden muss als Paket Austräger das fast will ich hier echt nicht aufmachen weil das ja es ist so es ist es ist eine Tatsache und jemand muss da jemand müsste das ändern.
Wir erstmal in dieser Sendung nicht.
Aber wir brauchen das an V und falls letzter Teil dieses Kommentars schreibt,
zum Thema tendenziöse Berichterstattung ich dachte dass es eigentlich klar wäre was damit gemeint ist da es bereits durch alle Medien gegen,
eines der Beispiele aus der jüngsten Zeit ist z.b. der Krieg in der Ukraine Link auf,
Auseinandersetzung Streit um Berichterstattung in der ARD.
Keine also als der Krieg Konflikt im im Mittelpunkt stand,
weiterhin weiß auch das Verfassungsgericht zeigte dass die Politik einen Einfluss auf die Medien hat hier Link auf Zeit
die Diskussion Einfluss der Gremien und ZDF und die ganze Debatte um wie isst man Vornamen Brenda.
Panda Panda brenda Vornamen macht man sich doch nicht.
Nikolaus Brender ZDF Chefredakteur der dann nicht verlängert wurde.
Da hat glaube ich die hessische CDU noch mit die Finger im Spiel,
Abschluss dieses Kommentars und auch sonst sind die Berichte wirklich tendenziös contra Trump contra Putin Pro Bargeld Abschaffung contra Erdogan pronator,
visitor säuft also dieses Wort.
Tendenziös finde ich ein bisschen terentius weil das sozusagen immer gerne verwendet wird um.
Ein schon mal irgendwas zu unterstellen hatte verzagen in irgendeiner Maßnahmen und einer Meinungsäußerung eine Absicht steckt
um irgendetwas zu befördern et cetera ich meine ehrlich gesagt,
Satellit User kann man wirklich schnell mal weglassen Bezug also contra Trump contra Putin
verärgert da fällt mir eine Menge ein und da haben wir glaube ich hier in dieser Sendung auch schon die ganze Menge zusammengetragen warum das sozusagen
nachvollziehbar ist wenn es eine solche Berichterstattung gibt das kann man natürlich jetzt anders sehen aber ehrlich gesagt diese Aufstellung finde ich es bisschen skurril
Pro bargeldabschaffung ja naja pronator ich weiß nicht was hast du da noch einen Kommentar zu.
Also das tendenziöse in Berichterstattung ist gar nicht unbedingt.
Wie man über etwas berichtet es sei denn man berichtet so wie die Bild-Zeitung.
Im Prinzip geht es über die Auswahl über welche Themen berichtet man über welche Themen berichtet man nicht man kann sich da jetzt stundenlang mit auseinandersetzen das irgendwie in,
nimm jetzt mal Beispiel Tagesschau irgendwie etwas.
Dargestellt wurde in einer Form die einen bestimmten Schluss nahelegt und einen anderen und anderen einen anderen Schluss nicht.
Kann man tun und es ist es ist unmöglich anders zu berichten.
Er will es geht gar nicht anders deswegen wurden ja schon vor weiß nicht wie viele Jahrzehnte das jetzt erst die taz gegründet um
eine andere Auswahl zu treffen ja um Springer und öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk für derzeit etwas entgegenzusetzen ja,
deswegen gibt es hier einen Podcast über Netzpolitik um dem Thema.
In im Rahmen dieser Sendung irgendwie mehr Aufmerksamkeit zu verschaffen als es vielleicht in,
den Systemmedien die gleiche Scheiße Systemmedien den tennishosen gleichschalten Systemmedien bekommt ja und damit ein Angebot zu machen für leute Leute für die die sich für das jetzt für dieses Thema interessieren.
Und also eine objektive Berichterstattung ist allein deshalb schon nicht möglich weil man ja weil ich eine Auswahl treffe,
also spezifisch für diese Sendung sowie hier gibt's die Tendenz bestimmte Themen auszuwählen und andere nicht weil die Sendung lang ist und wir irgendwie eine Mischung machen Mischung machen müssen was wichtig ist und was nicht.
Ja bist auch tendenziös.
Wir sind ziemlich tendenziös,
und er hat alles sehr wichtig finde ich also eigentlich ist jedem der sich ein bisschen mit.
Dreht sich für Politik und Berichterstattung interessiert die müsste sowieso klar sein dass man sich,
mehrere verschiedene Quellen verschafft und zwar auch gezielt ich nenne mal Beispiele aus meinem Medienkonsum würde ich eigentlich selten Rede aber ich höre z.b. diesen Podcast von Ben Shapiro.
Hardcore Republikaner der USA ziemlich krügermann um zu
einfach nur um meine Wahrnehmung dahin zu balancieren wie der über Sachen nachdenkt,
ich höre mir irgendwie auch Evis jemand wie Sam Harris an und wenn irgendwo in dem in den Aufreger der USA irgendeiner durchgezogen wird
und sei es sogar an Alex Jones oder dieser pettersen oder was auch immer dann gucke ich mir an was die sagen,
und ich habe ich lese was was ich von konkret bis Welt vom von der Wirtschaftswoche bis bis in den Mond diplomatique lese ich dicke.
Gerade damit ich erkenne wo,
irgendwo das liegt was im was ich am Ende glaube wo ist die Argumente gibt die mich am besten versorgen,
und das ist irgendwie ne das ist das eine Aufgabe die kann man
muss man selber wahrnehmen und jedes Mal wenn ich mich hinsetze sag jetzt nicht aber ein Medium und dann dann Dresche ich darauf rum das jetzt aber in dieses Thema in der Tagesschau falsch behandelt wurde ja Mayen
dann ja mein Gott dann muss ich irgendwie mir ein anderes Medium suchen für mich persönlich ist das etwas.
Sehr spannendes angenehmes gut verwende ich einen Großteil meiner Lebenszeit darauf mich irgendwie zu informieren,
und es ist ja geht natürlich andererseits Leute die das nicht tun die sich dann auf eine Quelle fokussieren da diese was dass ich z.b. sagen mein nach in Konsum ist 20:15 Uhr Tagesschau,
wenn wenn sich die Leute auf einen nachrichtenkonsum konzentrieren da bin ich immer noch sehr viel glücklicher wenn die irgendwo in den dritten Programmen ZDF oder oder der ARD landen.
Advenire wobei im Pro7 oder RTL2 Nachrichten landen und,
ich denke da muss man dazu muss man ganz klar sagen dass das einfach eine sehr viel seriöser Berichterstattung ist das die eine Haltung hat.
Das ist ein klarer Fall.
Und dass sie nicht objektiv Bericht erstatten können ergibt sich einfach allein aus der Sache dass sie Bericht erstatten die haben halt nur eine Viertelstunde,
ich werde erst durch den ich darüber aufregen könnte als wir damals die Wahl Software letztes Jahr auseinander genommen haben da wurde 20:15 Uhr der Tagesschau gesagt die Sicherheitslücken Gang geschlossen,
völliger Unsinn also falsch fake-news so ne.
Und das da immer der könnte ich ja also das da davon wirklich tatsächlich hat mich das geärgert,
weil die waren ja nicht geschlossen der Bericht war ja von dem Tag und der ist überhaupt nichts passiert jetzt auch nachher nichts passiert gleichzeitig,
ist mir auch klar soll ich auch einen Vortrag beim Kongress zu dem Thema glaube ich nachher noch mal in den Fragen zumindest gesagt ist mir schon auch klar dass die dass die Tage schon nicht sagen nicht als erste Meldung sagen wird er die Wahl wird gehackt.
So und die wird jetzt ausfallen weil es da eben auch darum ging das Vertrauen der Bürgerinnen und Bürger in diesen in dieses Wahlverfahren irgendwie zu erhalten insofern,
wenn wenn man sagt hier hat jemand tendenziös Bericht erstattet das erlaube ich ab jetzt nur noch.
Wenn mal ein Positivbeispiel gibt wo das nicht der Fall war und das wird glaube ich niemanden gelingen.
Hand hatte ich hatte ich gesagt dass Andre das andere Meister dass er genannt hat bei netzpolitik.org das fand ich ziemlich beste come here, meinen investigativjournalist die wir alle hier kennen und schätzen der sagt,
netzpolitik.org macht Journalismus mit Haltung gebunden an journalistische Prinzipien ganz klarer Fall.
Mit einer klaren politischen Haltung die auch klar kommuniziert ist das wär der einzige Vorwurf dem jetzt gleich der Tagesschau machen könnte wenn man sagt wenn ihr über die bargeldabschaffung positiv,
berichtet was jetzt hier ja behauptete kann ich prüfen dass man dann da sagt okay was ist da eure Haltung und die Abschaffung von Bargeld ja.
Sicherlich wird das jetzt wenn Leute es ungern hören,
führt einerseits ganz klar in Überwachungsgesellschaft ja weil du dann irgendwie weil die Finanzströme sehr viel besser überwacht werden können,
aber wenn wenn es z.b. in wie solche Regelungen gab wird wo der vor ein paar Jahren diskutiert zu sagen ok Bargeldzahlungen über 10000 € oder sowas werden illegalisieren oder 15 war das glaube ich damals ne.
Sonderregelung unter der würde ich nur sehr wenige Male in meinem Leben ernsthaft leiden und eine ganze Menge Leute den ganze Menge scheiße machen.
Würden der jeden Tag runterladen und die tun das,
zu meinem Leidwesen weil weil die weniger Steuern zahlen aus den wir die Pension für tomorrow bezahlen können eine.
Sorry das scheiße längerer
bei längerer also sucht euch bitte verschiedene Quellen und findet eure eigene Meinung und gerade da wo nicht die eigene Meinung vertreten wird lohnt sich es in meinen Augen immer am meisten hinzuhören,
wenn das vernünftig also wenn der vernünftige Teilnehmer der Diskurses sind.
Bin jetzt auf ein bisschen beunruhigt weil ich sehe jetzt in dem Kommentar auch noch so ein Bus da,
ich weiß nicht genau wie es formulieren soll aber dieses.
Etwas was allgemein so gesehen wird da gibt es einen Bericht auf dem Internet 2.
Die in eine andere Richtung war es und dann wird das genommen und dann wird damit irgendwie Haustieren gegangen als wäre das jetzt sozusagen auf der Beleg dafür
das auch alle anderen Schlechtigkeiten die man sich nur vorstellen kann damit auch automatisch irgendwie belegt und das ist so ein bisschen ich will dir das jetzt hier nicht unterstellen Dimitri ja nur.
Gedanken Anregung das ist schon so ein bisschen auf dieser Nährboden aus dem diese gesamte.
Bewegungen des mal unter der wir jetzt auch global so leiden so ein bisschen die Nahrung bezieht so dieses
da kann ja was nicht stimmen hier guck mal auf dem Internet da ist ja irgendwie David ja etwas ganz anderes gesagt und dann steigern sich die Leute da rein ich melde ich muss
ich habe letzten Tage mit mit einer gewissen Fassungslosigkeit mir auch mal wieder so gegeben wie viele Leute mittlerweile Deezer flat earth,
Theorie Obi Anhänger jetzt keine Massenbewegung oder sowas aber das ist überhaupt mehr als irgendwie einen würden verstrahlten Menschen gibt
wir sind auch nur ernsthaft
mehr als 10 Sekunden lang in seinem Hirn von links nach rechts schiebt es dass dass das haut mich ehrlich gesagt schon um nein die treffen sich zu Konferenzen und und und
verkaufen und welche Modelle irgendwie Wiesel also immer das haben,
das haben die Ägypter schon vor 3000 Jahren irgendwie final abgeschlossen das Thema und ihr kommt dann kommen die Leute mit sowas,
was ist kaputt.
Tim the flat Earth society has members all around the globe.
Erinnerung.
Heißt der TS heißt die andere Lösung ist auch nicht setzt euch bitte alle hin und und gibt euch nur noch irgendwie frontal Beschallung von der einen Wahrheit das ist aber gewiss,
das einerseits irgendwelche,
teilweise auch in welche gefrustet und Journalisten die sich dann da irgendwie von oben bis unten an irgendwelchen Leitmedien abarbeiten und so nah dass das ja auch,
XPhone und dann landen sie am Ende ihren vorbei wie heißen die dieses compact oder was ne dieses diese Spinner Magazin oder oder oder irgendwo im Internet auf YouTube so nah und,
die ist nämlich auch nicht ich meine Katze ist anhören aber so aber das entscheiden ist das dass wir alle damit leben müssen dass es,
eine eine komplexe Welt ist in der wir leben in der unterschiedliche Entitäten ihre Sicht darauf äußern und in der ist eigentlich ein nur ein Weg gibt Wahrheit zu finden das ist Wissenschaft,
alles andere ist Theorie und,
wir müssen es ja natürlich irgendwie und Ziele verfolgen Interessen aber ein öffentlich-rechtlicher Rundfunk ist eben die.
Eine ganz gute Möglichkeit die Leute von diesen Interessen freizuhalten.
Wir haben in dieser in diesem im Bereich dieser Debatte ja auch genau darüber gesprochen warum wir hier
und die Podcast Millionen entgehen lassen und nicht unsere die höhere Aufmerksamkeit an andere verkaufen weil wir nicht irgendwie dass das putzlied von euren Rohren werden wollen.
Und naja.
Genau also nicht nichts ist nichts ist perfekt wir nicht auf da draußen nicht manche Lösungen sind aber besser als andere,
und das ist unser Blickwinkel die wir auf diesen öffentlichen Rundfunk haben im nur also da gibt's sicherlich viel scheiße da gibt's auch ein paar korrupte und Paul und rote und auch Leute die irgendwie dummes Zeug reden.
Und dann wird auch Geld verballert ganz klarer Fall.
Wäre allerdings in einem anderen System,
ja auch so und vielleicht sogar auch noch schlimmer gibt genug Beispiele weltweit will es nicht gleich wieder mit Fox News ankommen das ein bisschen extrem aber,
und man muss sich ein bisschen davon trennen dass dass das alles irgendwie perfekt sein kann oder Perfektion an Stall so anschreiben kann man das ja gerne erreichen wird man es halt enie das ist ja auch nicht anders
man muss halt um die eine Haltung haben und muss eine Grundhaltung haben und mir gefällt die Grundhaltung öffentlichen Rundfunks an der Stelle ein dich erstmal so.
So haben wir Feedback zillow als Handschrift bekommen.
Komme das.
Und zwar von Manuel er sagt
Thema Assange ich höre viel Ironie und Sarkasmus aber jemand der damals den Spirit um collateral murder und so weiter nicht mitbekommen hat versteht den Sarkasmus nicht nicht falsch verstehen ich höre ich ja der things waren Städte im Asyl einfach das machen sollen was man halt immer süße macht Holzhacken oder so,
wenn das denn in der Botschaft geht ja der der Platz hat er dich ein bisschen eingeschränkt Nikon kommentiert dazu,
darf an dieser Stelle auf Folge 2 Verweise der erklärt ihr virtavia Song shindy in der Situation gelandet ist.
Ja also wichtiger Punkt gerade als gerade das Thema Assange Wikileaks haben wir wirklich in letzten Jahren hier selten noch mal rekapituliert.
Bin mir gar nicht ich glaube es auf den 26.03 der Vortrag von daniel Domscheit-Berg und Julian Assange wo das in dessen Folge dann Wikileaks noch mal so richtig Fahrt gewann.
Danke auch noch mal für den Verweis auf die Folge 2 in der wird es offenbar sehr sehr gut.
Oder weiß ich sehr gut aber in der besoffen war im Detail erklärt haben ich habe sie nicht noch mal gehört.
Mit Wikileaks ist das so eine Sache natürlich das ist eine eine Lieblings Plattform gewesen die oder ist es immer noch die angetreten ist,
leben mit einer mit radikaler Wahrheit also eine fundiert liegt das liegt lügen nicht,
diese in die Welt zu schaffen und die sich übrigens auch worüber wir gerade gesprochen hat die den Anspruch hatte die Sachen mehr oder weniger RO.
Auf ihre Plattform zu setzen um den Medien etwas zu geben mit dem sie arbeiten können also quasi Fakten und Medien sollen das dann bitteschön verarbeiten die sollen raus machen was sie wollen,
ja was ne glaube ich immer noch sehr sinnvolle Herangehensweise ist.
Viele viele,
Organisationen die unter Wikileaks gelitten haben ging invelos mit Bankhaus Julius Bär und BKA und solchen Sachen und dann hat diese Geschichte des Lieblings aber auch natürlich.
Verschiedene Phasen durchlaufen gab es dann irgendwie dieses collateral murder video in dem gezeigt wurde die Soldaten,
der US Armee mit einem Hubschrauber mehrere eindeutige Zivilist
töten unter denen sich eben einen Journalist dann auch noch befand es gab diese diplomatic
cables also diese Botschaft die Passion die dann da in großer Menge gelegt wurden beide stammten,
offenbar kann man sagen aus den Händen von,
der US-Armee Angehörigen Personen männing die in Knast gekommen ist dafür weil sie verraten wurde von dem inzwischen verstorbenen,
Visa noch bei Adria Lemgo,
die melden sich anvertraut hatte die dann wiederum begnadigt wurde von von Obama kurz vor Ende seiner Amtszeit und
jetzt als Aktivisten unterwegs ich glaube ich auch irgendwo kandidiert fehlen.
Na ja genau.
Und dann,
diese und uns wurde politisch immer heißer unruhig gelegt und eben auch um Julien Assange und irgendwann 2010 hat 2011 war das eben dass er dann auf einmal die.
Tatsächlich,
im Lehrbuch beschrieben ne Paste in jede Verschwörungstheorie dass Julian Assange daneben sexuelle ist Eva gehen,
irgendwo zwischen,
massiver Belästigung und Vergewaltigung nachgesagt wurde oder Edison beschuldigt wurde von gleich zwei Personen und dann entzog er sich eben der der Strafverfolgung durch Schweden das ist eine sehr sehr lange Geschichte.
Während derer Wikileaks eben auch immer weiter und auch Julien Assange immer weiter in so eine.
Sehr verschwörerisch Welt Interpretation sich,
gab was auffällig klar ist wenn irgendwie Hillary Clinton sagt why don't we just one the sky und du das ist sie wirklich mit so gut wie jeder Regierungen dieser Erde verschissen hast dass du irgendwann,
echt ein bisschen paranoid wird und das heißt ja nicht dass sie nicht hinter dir her sind.
Jetzt genau.
Das ist bei Julie Ersatz auch echt tatsächlich der Fall und ein.
Tragischer Fall.
In vielerlei Hinsicht eben auch weil es darin mündete dass diese dass die liegst der Hacks der E-Mails von Demokraten.
Tatsächlich eine ein sehr wichtiger Finger an der Waage waren die die US-Wahl entschieden habe ich will nicht sein dass Hillary Clinton ohne diese liegt gewonnen hätte aber sagen wir so die haben auf jeden Fall nicht dazu beigetragen dass sie,
verliert die haben ja auf jeden Fall nicht dazu beigetragen dass sie gewinnt und.
Eine gewisse Russland Nähe wird eben dieser ganzen Wikileaks Familie auch in zunehmendem Maße nachgesagt insbesondere.
Was hatte denn seine Sendung bei Russia Today also was ist da muss man gar nichts nachsagen das kann man auch nachschauen das war alles da und das Warschau auch immer,
etwas skurril und plötzlich ist es so es ist fast unmöglich diese Person Assange derzeit überhaupt noch unvoreingenommen,
und widerspruchsfrei zu erklären das ist einfach die die die Situation in der sich befindet sie so mega krass ich würde ihm überhaupt nicht absprechen dass er Alter in diese ganze,
Projekt reingegangen ist hehre Ziele hatte ja die vielleicht auch immer noch.
Wetter immer noch.
Hatte auch genau was ich gerade sagen also die hatte auch immer noch nur die Frage hat er noch.
Die Möglichkeit überhaupt nicht so in der aktuellen Realität ob noch so
zu korrigieren und und und auszurichten dass sein Beitrag hier wirklich noch hilfreich ist vielleicht auch noch mal zur Erklärung weil es ja auch immer Ironie und Sarkasmus Vitamin dann irgendwann mal Julio Sanchez,
getauft in dem Moment als er dann eben in dieser Botschaft unter kam er.
Was wollen wir damit ausdrücken ich kann es dir nicht genau sagen aber es ist ebenso ansehen inhalt wie sehen Inhalt,
gespalten sehen auf der einen Seite den wichtigen Beitrag den das Wikileaks frägt und das ist ja nicht nur er
das sind ja auch viele andere Leute drumherum die dieses Projekt am Anfang auch extrem ernst genommen habe an dieser Stelle vielleicht mal noch einen Verweis auf einen Podcast nicht gemacht habe in meiner Reihe CARE da habe ich ja mich mal mit Rob,
Kornkreis unterhalten sehr schöne Sendung Holland und die Hacker wer das noch nicht gehört hat sollte mal reinhören allein schon deshalb um einfach auch mal diese ganze Hacker history in Europa
zu verstehen also speziell auch die Beziehung die die Holländer und die Deutschen da in 80er 90er Jahren aufgebaut haben.
Er erläutert in der Sendung auch seine Rolle
blindfall collateral murder weil er ihm dass dieser Gruppe gehörte die eben dieses Video mit aufbereitet haben und was sozusagen seine Intention war ja dann auch betroffen und Nachforschung Twitter DMC
hat mir folgende Sendung darf ich auch aufgegriffen,
oder kann man immer auch sehr schön nachvollziehen in welchem Spannungsfeld auch übrigens der auf der Club da gelandet ist ja,
na also.
Klarer Fall der also der Club vor allem ist ja jetzt auch kein Geheimnis des TV Holland Stiftung die Institution ist die für Wikileaks in Deutschland die Spenden einnimmt und verwaltet.
Wenn ich die Spenden sondern projektbezogen
muss man dazu sagen ja also projektbezogen Spenden einsammelt das ist also nicht Geld was irgendwie Assange auf seinem Konto wo parkt und für den Fall dass er irgendwie normal rauskommt sich sein
Dim Sum mit vergoldeten da geht's halt um den Betrieb von Servern der geht's eben um Aldi ganz bringt Intro warum die auch so ein bisschen verschwunden sind hinter.
Dieser öffentlichen Wahrnehmung von Assange und das war's auch so ein Teil unserer Zurückhaltung er hat sich selbst in letzten Jahren so sehr,
die Vordergrund gespielt und Versagen auch bisschen wichtiger gemacht als seine Rolle im Projekt Wikileaks tatsächlich ist ja
kontrolliert offenbar immer noch diesen Twitter-Account dann gabs diese ganzen Annäherungsversuche und durchgeführten Annäherungen und Kommunikations austausche mit der Tram Familie
wo man sich halt fragt so alter was leitet dich jetzt eigentlich gerade noch ja ist es jetzt eigentlich nur noch deine,
federas nachvollziehbar dass du irgendwie deinen Arsch retten willst aber passt das dann eigentlich noch zu diesem Projekt und ist das was du da machst nicht er etwas was du unter deinem Namen machen solltest dass du dann auch stehen solltest
und nicht das Projekt immer wieder so damit verhaften was im viele Brüste Projektes
betrieben werden dann eigentlich in Mitleidenschaft jetzt also das ist sozusagen
insgesamt Gebilde was wir immer sehen wenn wir von ihm sprechen und ich glaube so unsere Ironie diwodaso mit reinbringen ist eben auch so ein Ausdruck seine gewissen Hilflosigkeit viva.de mit seiner Person jetzt umgehen sollen weil
in der Situation kann sich da jetzt eh nichts klären.
Das wird einfach nur noch Voranschreiten des Drama.
Ja Drama gibt es auch in Deutschland so ist ja nicht ne wir haben da ja so Ämter und Behörden,
unter anderem den Verfassungsschutz der hier schon oft kritisch behandelt wurde.
Da sind wir auch ein bisschen tendenziös würde ich sagen.
So tendenziös wir haben so unsere Zweifel ob das mit diesem Verfassungsschutz eigentlich so eine gute Idee ist nicht unbedingt so sehr jetzt vom Titel her
darf ich jetzt nichts gegen Verfassung kann gerne geschützt werden auch wenn das nicht unbedingt jetzt die Aufgabe einer einzigen Organisation sein sollte sondern eigentlich er aller Leute ne auch der Bundesregierung auch der CSU,
Bühring sich auch noch mal wieder dran erinnern der Verfassungsschutz als Geheimdienst ist ein,
schwieriges Unternehmen und er ist es vorallem auch gerade aus der Erfahrung heraus über letzten Jahren gemacht haben mit dem Fall NSU.
Da werden halt Nazi Strukturen teilweise mitfinanziert und es ist auch immer wieder erstaunlich,
wie sehr der Verfassungsschutz dann doch immer wieder involviert ist finanziell involviert ist personell involviert ist so dass man sich manchmal fragt,
haben die eigentlich mit den Nazis da was am laufen ja also beobachten Sie die so intensiv um dadurch die Verfassung zu schützen oder werden hier nicht eigentlich eher schon die Naht.
Dass die Frage oder gibt es einen interessanten Bericht,
von einem früheren afd-mitglied Namens Franziska Schreiber die wohl Frau Petry damals als in der AFD noch was zu sagen hatte irgendwie irgendwo gleitet hatte ich verstehe war das ihre Assistentin.
Heißt war die nicht in der jungen Alternative er ich habe da verdirbt verschiedene Stationen durch wichtig ist dass sie aus der AFD ausgestiegen ist und jetzt ein,
Buch veröffentlicht inside AFD,
das ist glaube ich dass das ist das entscheidende sie hat sind jetzt auf dem spontan nicht genau wo ihre ihre verschiedenen Rollen die sie indem in dem Laden hatte aber offenbar nah genug dran.
So jetzt schreibt sie also in diesem Buch.
Also sie war ehemaliges Vorstandsmitglied der jungen Alternative.
Und wie das so ist wenn du irgendwie die,
im Vorstand der Junge Organisation bis dann hast Du natürlich auch beste Beziehung in die alte Organisation und die schreibt er sie jetzt in ihrem Buch
es habe also mehrere Treffen gegeben zwischen dem Hans-Georg Maaßen und der Frauke Petry,
und bei einem dieser Treffen habe dermaßen der Frauke Petry Tipps gegeben wie die Partei eine Beobachtung durch den Verfassungsschutz vermeiden können.
Das ist interessant weil die AFD nicht durch den Verfassungsschutz beobachtet wird zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt die Linkspartei aber sehr wohl.
Wüsste nicht dass hat jemand aufgehört hätte.
Zocke versichern Links.
Setz auch gefährlich ne und vor allem habe er ja dann zu einem Ausschlussverfahren gegen den Björn höcke geraten ein der Rechtsaußen dieser Partei.
Was ich deswegen noch man in zweiten Skandal finde.
Unabhängig davon dass das Björn höcke sowieso irgendwie ganz woanders hingehört als da wo er jetzt ist.
Dieses unerhört dass der Inlandsgeheimdienst,
sich an eine politische Partei wendet und Empfehlungen gibt wie sie sich zu verhalten habe völlig also irgendwie so.
Damit sie nicht beobachtet wird.
Ich würde Ihnen empfehlen,
ich würde Ihnen empfehlen einen anderen Kandidaten aufzustellen ich würde Ihnen empfehlen Erde stehen bevor ihr wie er geht zu jeder Partei und sagt dann mal euch würde ich irgend übrigens empfehlen Folgendes zu tun rasche rasche ich habe hier so ein Aktenordner der echt ungünstig ne.
Schöne Pattaya haben sie da.
Körperteil haben sie da wäre schade wenn diese Aktenordner richtig sind Norden auf dem Rückweg in der S-Bahn verliere.
So eine eine Einflussnahme des Geheimdienstes Inlandsgeheimdienst auf die Politik.
Ist sowieso absoluter Wahnsinn und zwar egal ob das irgendwie die dem Prinzip die Empfehlung des absägen einzelner Mitglieder ist.
Oder die Empfehlung wie man einer Beobachtung durch den Verfassungsschutz ins geh entgehen kann das also das dass es nicht nur das discussed daran ist nicht nur dass er hier mit der AFD an Bandit,
das ganze ist auch dass er überhaupt auf eine politische Partei Einfluss nimmt das ist dann natürlich auch noch hier in einem Prinzip wohlmeinenden,
Sinne gegenüber Nana Nazipartei macht
sind besorgte Bürger die nicht jetzt bitte nicht die Gebühren Debatte durch eine AFD Debatte
Aldi sind alles keine Nazis diese die wollen alle nur was dass ich Geschlechtergerechtigkeit im Asylrecht oder so super.
Das ist auf jeden Fall das was ich auch krass finde ist dass das gerade wieder so ein Thema zu sein scheint was ihr wieder da ferner liefen läuft.
Und interessanterweise wie war das denn da kannst du eine wunderschöne da kannst du eine wunderschöne Formulierung dass das Innenministerium hat jetzt mehr oder weniger alles bestätigt,
das ist also diese Treffen gab also hätte mit mit der früheren afd-chefin Petry sich vor 3 Jahren zweimal zu Gesprächen getroffen bestätig das Innenministerium
und dann sagen sie der Inhalt dieser Gespräche unterliegt irgendwie der dem Kernbereich exekutiver Eigenverantwortung,
das finde ich sehr schön Kernbereich.
Kernbereich exekutiver.
Eigenverantwortung oder so du kannst nur ganz kurz Kernbereich exekutiver und Maßen so eine findest du das Kernbereich ist so ein Begriff.
Wenn ich einen Kernbereich und Verfassungsschutz denken weißt du wann ich dann denke an online und Online-Durchsuchung,
und und Staatstrojaner weil da war immer vom Kernbereich der Privatsphäre der Kernbereich der persönlich persönlichen Lebensführung oder sowas der Begriff Kernbereich kommt immer quasi dass das unantastbare,
das ist immer der Törnberichte der Kernbereich da darf keiner dran und hier der Kernbereich der exekutiven Verantwortung oder Eigenverantwortung.
Verantwortung.
Da dürfen wir nicht dran tippen,
da können wir nicht machen das ist hier der Geheimnis Chef behandelt mit den mit den besorgten Bürgern Anja mit den mit den
Holocaust leugnen und den Leuten die Hausverbot haben in Buchenwald so ne aber so ne der Kernbereich exekutiver Eigenverantwortung
finde ich echt geil.
Das richtige.
Erdogan Wikipedia Artikel der Kernbereich exekutiver Eigenverantwortung auch geheimbereich oder arkanbereich genannt bezeichnet in Indien
initiativ Beratungs und Handlungsbereich der Exekutive welcher der parlamentarischen Kontrolle entzogen ist durch ihn soll die Gewaltenteilung gewahrt werden indem ein hinein regieren der Legislative verhindert wird der Umfang dieses Kernbereichs lässt sich nicht generell bestimmen vielmehr ist der unter Abwägung der verfassungsrechtlichen
Aufgaben von Regierung und Parlament im Einzelfall zu bestimmen, sogar noch was gelernt ich habe ehrlich gesagt gedacht hat werden Neologismus.
Nécessaire.
Ein ein ein Neonazi logismus.
Das ist so gemeint ja.
Ja na ja schauen wir uns mal an wie das weitergeht ich find das nicht gut dass du jetzt gerade an den Shownotes Scrolls Tims ne.
Entschuldigung das tut mir sich jetzt extrem leid ich wollte noch hinzufügen dass laut dem Tagesspiegel Bericht der nicht nur so ist das,
diese Empfehlung ausgesprochen sei sondern dass Frau Petry gegenüber der Franziska Schreiber ja berichtet habe das dermaßen der Partei
Zitat wohlgesonnen sei und dass man doch sich diesen Vorteil wiederum Zitat nicht verspielen sold.
Also da haben wir sozusagen jetzt den Chef eines.
Extreme im Geheimen arbeiten in der Heimdienst ist dessen vorgegebenes Ziel imri Verfassungsschutz ist hence the name ja ich halte diese Personalie für nicht mehr tragbar,
wenn dass ich in irgendeiner Form.
Bestätigen lassen dass ich schwierig Aussage gegen Aussage es gibt ja eine eidesstattliche Versicherung das ist jetzt nicht wenig das ist natürlich auch noch nicht.
Bewiesen.
Die eidesstattliche Versicherung ist natürlich auch so ein so ein onguard ne weil die Wendy Franziska Streiber das an Eides statt versichert.
Dann bin ich ja mal gespannt ob unser lieber Freund Maßen dass im Rahmen des Kernbereichs seiner exekutiven Eigenverantwortung geboten sieht dass er vielleicht auch etwas an Eides statt versichert.
Ja das wär mal ganz gut.
Wenn er das nicht tut kann man daraus seine Schlüsse ziehen wenn das tut aber unter Umständen eben auch ne.
Ja aber der Kernbereich.
Ich habe den Eindruck dass der also ich kann mir das natürlich sehr sehr gut vorstellen da ich meine wer sich mal mit wer sich ein bisschen mit ihm,
sei mal auseinandergesetzt hat oder so der vermutet hinter dem man jetzt nicht unbedingt die das linksliberale Herz eines.
Links grün versifften.
Nee nicht so wir lassen das mal so stehen.
Das Buch hat es liegt aber ansonsten auch um gute Wellen denn vonseiten der AFD sind jetzt juristische juristische Schritte angekündigt worden die gute,
Erika Steinbach wird noch irgendwie lang in die sich lange Zeit in der CDU verirrt hatte.
Ja Rechtsausleger der CDU jetzt ist sie.
Gerechtes Rechtsausleger ist gute Hegewald im Trapez,
wie ist jetzt Chefin der der AFD Stiftung ne.
City ist die Linken de an.
Wie ist die Chefin der desiderius-erasmus-stiftung Parteien unterhalten der Stiftung.
Da kann man gut Geld unterbringen.
Da kann man das Geld unterbringen da ist jetzt die Erika Steinbach die die die Chefin der,
der der Stiftung Diesel juristisch Gegend eine Passage in dem Buch Vorgehen indem in dem behauptet wird sie habe schon im Wahlkampf 2013 ihre Geldbörse geöffnet und an die AFD gespendet.
Mich interessiert weil sowas sollte sicher eigentlich relativ einfach
nachweisen oder aus der Welt schaffen lassen und dann haben wir den Götz Kubitschek den rechten Verleger Götz Kubitschek der eine Unterlassungsaufforderung an den europa-verlag geschickt hat
denn in dem Buch inside AFD das im Europa Verlag erschienen ist wird geschildert
der habe gemeinsam mit mit dem AFD Rechtsaußen Björn höcke die Reden von Joseph Goebbels analysiert,
um daraus höcke reden mit modifizierten Versatzstücken abzuleiten und sie seien beide auf der Formel gewesen auf der Suche nach einer Formel gewesen die in den 30er Jahren
Beigabe zum Erfolg führte das ist natürlich völlig,
billige Vorstellung wenn man sich nur wenn man sich eine höcke Rede anhört heute unternehmen die Goebbels Rede sich anhört das ist da irgendwie dass sie auch nur im entferntesten sich mal bei Goggles Gomez informiert hätten ja also das ist.
Hat er wirklich völlig abwegig insofern bin ich mal gespannt ob der gute Götz Kubitschek hier Erfolg haben wird so oder so,
haben sie auf jeden Fall schon mal diesen Schilderung im Buch besonderen Auftrieb verliehen
und ich denke das ist doch tatsächlich jetzt mal so ein Buch was zu lesen insbesondere vielleicht die Hyänen nahezulegen ist die sich gerade,
wohl Gemeinwohl meint mit der AFD auseinandersetzen z.b. Verfassungsschutz Chef,
Hans-Georg Maaßen könnte dieses Buch mal lesen man wenn unter unseren Hörerinnen und Hörer noch Leute verblieben sind die sich mein ewiges und Substanzielles aus der Luft gegriffen ist plumpes afdg Wäsche immer noch geben hier habt ihr dann ein bisschen
substantiierte Riss IFDG wäsche von jemandem der dabei war.
Ja ich bin die Schreiber ist natürlich jetzt auch nicht unbedingt gerade die Person die man gleich auf Ihre Party auf die Party einladen möchte ist da auch hervorgetan gegen Rollo gegen das Gesetz Holocaust,
Leugnung vorgegangen weil Meinungsfreiheit zentrale Jannis sich alle irgendwie auch ein ein ein Rad am Wandern sind aber ganz interessant dass sie mittlerweile alle schon so dermaßen zerstritten sind
dass sie halt jetzt da so gegeneinander vorgehen denn man muss ja auch mal sagen also wenn man in dem braunen Sumpf und wie drinsteckt,
und dann den Aussteiger markiert und sagt hier seid ihr alle doof und riecht nach Lulu
also wären wir schon gesehen wie er das Zentrum für politische Schönheit da angegangen wurde ich glaube wenn du dann auch noch irgendwie aus dem eigene Fleisch bist dann hast Du wenig Spaß.
Ja also die die kriegt gerade natürlich die volle Ladung also das beschreibt sie auch in einem Interview dass ich noch mal in die Shownotes mit aufnehme die kriegt natürlich gerade,
wie bei Sumsi vergleicht ist mit einem Sekten austritt.
Was sie da gerade abkriegt und insofern das sollte sich wenigstens für diese Person lohnen insofern rate ich zur Lektüre dieses Buches Link machen wir mal in die schauen uns.
Genau sollte unser,
unter unseren Hörern irgendjemand sein der der Meinung ist es wär ja vielleicht mal ein interessantes Signal oder vielleicht alles gar nicht so schlimm solche Bewegung wie die AFD zu unterstützen
dann ist euch mal diesen ganzen Kram froya.
Level 5.
Das ist nicht so ne also wir haben ja einfach eine Partei wie wird von.
Rassisten und möchtegern verschissen gewählt und sehr sich selber so nicht.
Tim weißt du was die ins Trinkwasser machen.
So einiges.
Ich auch nicht aber eins steht fest die Frösche werden davon schwul.
Das ach ja.
Und jetzt haben sie ihn auch noch zensiert.
Boho also die Rede ist natürlich von Alex Jones sollt euch hellingst Jones,
noch kein Begriff sein was ich ehrlich gesagt kaum vorstellen kann nicht zuletzt wegen der Berichterstattung jetzt die letzten zwei Tage bereits über diesen Fall.
Infowars so sein.
Seine Plattform auf der dieser US-Amerikaner schon seit Jahren ranntet mit irgendwie an der krassen stimme ich weiß gar nicht wie man die schreiben soll also,
es am krummen oder am schreien und am Toben und sowieso der Prototyp des wutbürgers.
Was läuft heute alles gut reichsbürgers.
Jemand der halt in USA als vollkommen auf die Spitze treibt und einfach da eine 1.
Eine Öffentlichkeit Kommunikation betreibt die einfach geschwängert ist von,
Lügen und Wahrheiten Verschwörungstheorien und ihm ist auch einfach nicht eilig also da findet wirklich,
alles alles platzt ja weiß ich ganz genau wieder zur flachen Erde steht das habe ich jetzt noch nicht überprüft aber mir ist auch nicht mehr wundern wir das noch mit dazu kommt,
auf jeden Fall so nine eleven inside job das ist einfach der der totale Standard auf dem sich das alles aufbaut und natürlich wird er auch gehetzt
wie nichts Gutes gegen alle Einwanderer Flüchtlinge Hitzegrad bei drei nicht auf dem Baum ist.
Und nebenbei wenn er noch mal größere Teilmengen an irgendwelchen esoterischen Schutz Produkten noch gleich mit dazu verkauft damit man dann eben auch für die Apokalypse dir unmittelbar bevorsteht auch entsprechend,
gerüstet es jetzt kann man darüber natürlich lachen weil der Typ der macht irgendwie gutes remix Futter also,
ja da ist es im Internet so einiges zu hören und so für normal gebildete Menschen mein Schatz das halt an frag sie halt so ja was haben sie dem denn jetzt ins Wasser getan und.
Der treibt aber wirklich jetzt schon seit vielen Jahren sein.
Und zwar sehr erfolgreich ne also das ist wahrscheinlich keine Ahnung was der also mit sei mit seinem Shop
DataGrid wenn nur irgendwelche komischen Pillen und Kräuter und so prepper Kram irgendwie verkauft ne und Fanartikel für infowars.
Das ultimative soundso Öl für 60 $ oder so ne aber der Liebe die ganze Zeit die also irgendwelche.
Also schlangenöl literally ne.
Ganz offensichtliche.
4 Produkte unter health and wellness & preparedness für Palace der ganze prepper Scheiß.
Heute schon an die Apokalypse Ding.
Heute schon an die irgendwelche komischen Luftfilter und nee und entsprechendes auch sein Programm sehr kernig.
Der hatte doch auch was mit dieser komischen Verschwörungstheorie zu tun dass Hillary Clinton und der Podesta irgendwo in irgend einer Pizzeria.
Kinder pädophilenring unterhalten da ist dann irgendwie noch einer rein marschiert und hat darum geballert als Flexi Chance ist wirklich.
Bin im im Keller Regisseurs Pizza lass der gar keinen Keller hat.
Bisschen tendenziös würde ich sagen.
Ist was dran.
Der ist so wissen tendenziös und übrigens natürlich ein ganz besonders großer Fan von Donald Trump und und umgekehrt.
Umgekehrt Jumper ja auch schon in seiner Show.
Wenn du dir wenn du dir diesen wenn du dir das anguckst also ich gucke das immer mal wieder ja da kriegst du also das ist wieso.
Also das ist wie so ein visonia schwer schweres Zugunglück.
Mit einer brennenden Mülltonne.
Die gefüllt ist mit Fäkalien es ist ganz ganz fürchterlich
aber man kann auch nicht weg gucken und danach ist man fühlt man sich irgendwie dreckig und beklommen wenn man sich dann vor Augen führt was für eine Reichweiten Verein Einfluss,
Lisa wirklich voll Spinner in den USA hat dann.
Reserviert mir wirklich Angst und Bange und insofern.
Der in betrachte ich das natürliche wie auch als Hunde das ist das wenn jetzt wenn wenn wenn ich Donald Trump der Höhepunkt der amerikanischen voll Verblödung wäre dann wäre er das ne aber.
Lass auf jeden Fall gleich der nächste.
Unvorstellbar.
Dass der halt irgendwie da Millionenpublikum erreicht enormen politischen Einfluss erlangt mit einer mit einem Stoß vor dem Herrn,
und jedesmal jeden Scheiß den der der berichtet,
fünfmal sagte don't want you to see this und ne und kommt halt genau in diese Kerbe die wir am Anfang ja auch so sehr lange ausgeprägt haben noch mal mit diesem so nein Leute es gibt da drauf gibt da draußen Realität,
wie alle erfassen sie unterschiedlich und falsch und so weiter und haben alle unsere eigene Interessen und es gibt einige die man das ein bisschen besser,
Alex Jones und das ist eben das Spektrum was wir haben.
Das geht dir wieder hier ist das.
Es gibt eine hervorragende hervorragendes,
nehme das Dokumentation es ist schon was also John Oliver euch sicherlich bekannt lastweektonight hat mal bei Alex Jones der ganze Sendung gewidmet wo er sozialen die ganzen Wahnsinn schon wunderbar auseinandergenommen hat
nur es ist halt nun auch in der letzten Zeit,
was passiert was man sich halt was gar nicht mehr vorstellen kann sogar Alex Jones dreht jetzt noch mehr durch als ohnehin schon also was jetzt.
Der allerletzte Auslöser jetzt gerade war was er konkret gesagt hat in den letzten Sendungen das weiß ich nicht mehr so ganz genau was hat schon seit längerem echtes Problem ist ist diese helzel die da betrieben wird die.
Toppt einfach alles gab ja vor einiger Zeit als geht der laufende Meter über diese School Shootings also,
bewaffnete Überfälle meisten von Schülern aus der eigenen Schule oder Massaker,
veranstaltet werden unter den Schülern immer großes Drama ist findet fast täglich um die Altstadt,
Ich will jedes wird groß berichtet und eins über die halt wird das sehr groß berichtet war war das sogar das Handy Hook Shooting das war halt von daher noch ein besonders dramatisch Weißenseer stehsolarium Grundschüler gegen also.
Man kann sich das eh alles nicht vor.
Sandy Sandy Hook Shooting vielleicht kurz erwähnt,
Schießerei in den USA viele Kinder sterben und Alex Jones stellt sich hin und bezeichne die Eltern irgendwie als Statisten und Lügner ne.
Inhalt alles nicht stattgefunden.
Finn seine Anhänger diese Menschen belästigen.
Also richtig,
Salzgitter eine Familie die mittlerweile acht Mal umgezogen ist muss mal vorstellen also erstmal so dieses Trauma dass der um dein Kind genommen wird unserem jungen Alter das ist einfach.
Wir Kinder hat weiß wovon ich rede will keine Kinder hat will sie einfach was ganz schlimmes vor und.
Das ist einfach schon mal genug um wie dein Leben,
nachhaltig zu zerstören aber dann hast du es eben noch mit dieser possy hör und Hutter Zombies zu tun die einfach auf Kommando von so einem Vollhonk losmarschieren,
und dir dann auch noch dieses Restleben auch noch mal zur Hölle auf Erden machen da findet man überhaupt gar keine Worte mehr für
das hat jetzt immer weiter zugenommen weil er sich auch selber glaube ich mir unter feuer sieht der hat ja auch privat Ihr Problem deine Frau zieht getrennte t3c
egal Bräu gleichfalls bei der Auswahl ist nämlich auch vollkommen egal,
mach dich bloß halt auch immer wieder gefragt naja warum darf der eigentlich so überall alles von sich geben nayagan USA Meyer meinungsfrei da kann man ja sagen was man will sind wir uns irgendwie das Schlimmste auf der Sonne ist und alles nicht stimmt,
muss mal jetzt einfach mal so akzeptieren die große Frage ist ja auch immer wer bietet denn solch einer Meinung eine Plattform und du gabs so ein.
Facebook z.b. hat immer mal so ein bisschen weil die Leute sich beschwert haben so ein bisschen revoltiert da wurde mal für 30 Tage bei der Account gesperrt aber das war dann auch eben nur temporär darfst du verschiedene Maßnahmen also richtig mal.
Dem ganzen Treiben auf ihren Plattform
da ein Ende zu setzen hat sich irgendwie keiner so richtig getraut jetzt wie gesagt gab es ist ein bisschen Eskalation ich bin jetzt gerade nicht so sicher ob das konkret um dieses Handy hoch Geschichte ging oder ob sie es einfach dieses weitere Hetzerei ging,
Stingl zitterer war.
Also ist wird sie hatten offenbar wurde es nicht konkret benannt aber Word schreibt es liegt
daran dass er es gab zwei Videos in der irgendwie gegen Muslime gehetzt hat 1 wo er gegen Transgender Menschen gehetzt hat
und 1 wo irgendwie ein Erwachsener ein Kind auf dem Boden schubst und dass dass das diese jetzt eben zum Anlass genommen wurden.
Ach das ist wahrscheinlich auch,
dass man auch nicht selten solche Fake Videos über die kenne ich weiß es nicht genau aber gibt's ja auch eine ganze Menge Fickvideos dir darum gehen wo einfach komplett aus dem Kontext gerissen irgendwas.
Nun,
war die Aufregung wohl aufgrund dieser jüngsten thematischen Eskalation so groß dass die ganzen Plattform nicht mehr so richtig ignorieren konnten was ankam.
Auch in der Podcast Landschaft kann das irgendwie an also ja gib dann schönen Bericht in GP was im schon gehört hast.
Bin ich gestern zu eingeschlafen.
Accidente Tech Podcast wo Marco arment Veeam also das aus seiner Perspektive erzählt hat dass sie mit dem auch extrem viele Leute,
angeschrieben haben weil ja auch in seinem seiner Podcast suche seiner Podcast App Deezer Podcast gefunden wird tatsächlich hat er kein eigenes Verzeichnis sondern befragt eigentlich nur den iTunes-Store wo er ist schon uns halt noch gelistet war,
da mein eigenen Filter davor gesetzt weil ihm das jetzt einfach zu dicke Cham,
und er da auch ein Verantwortung sieht was ich absolut unterstütze diese Grundhaltung,
2 Tage später kam dann aber auch Apple aus dem Busch und hat gesagt ok schluss jetzt hier dieses Programm verstößt gegen die Richtlinien dieses Podcast verzeihen.
ITunes Hose der keine Podcasts hat ja nur ein Verzeichnis letzteres ist das eine große Datenbank mit Adressen von feed.
Aber es gibt da im relativ klare Regeln wo halt drin steht hier wenn du irgendwie rum hältst oder wenn du irgendwie Nippel zeigst na also Porno ist halt verboten wie immer
dann wollen wir dich hier nicht nur so richtig viel exekutiert,
wird das aus meiner Beobachtungen nicht das heißt nicht dass es nicht stattfindet aber es gab erstaunt ich will nicht Fälle,
letzten 10 Jahre also mir fällt das nicht kein einziger ein,
muss wirklich mal so eine Auseinandersetzung gab ihm wie mit dem AppStore ja also wo gesagt wurde hier dieser Podcast darf arbeiten hier nicht sein und Apple,
18 Uhr da kommt ja mal wieder Zensur Wort,
wo ist halt staatliche Maßnahme geht's eben um die Teilnahme an einer privaten Plattform nichts anderes ist das Apple Podcast Verzeichnis naja auf jeder hat Apple an diesen Schritt,
unternommen,
kurz darauf geht wohl auch Facebook und dann auch Google dadurch so seinen Zugwagen dass sie eben auch beschlossen haben die entsprechenden Profilseiten pages von Alex Jones auf Facebook
bzw im auch den populären YouTube-Kanal mit immerhin 2,3 Millionen subscriber
auch noch komplett einzustellen und zu löschen und auch unwiederbringlich dich zum.
Ja kann man sich natürlich fragen warum hat das überhaupt so lange gedauert ja braucht's da erst Apple und überhaupt wie steht Apple da eigentlich jetzt wirklich da weil es gibt zwar im AppStore durchaus noch die app
für Ina wo sein Stream Programm,
sonst empfangenes also so ein customized App um seinen Stream zu empfangen damals Apple naja diese App hätte jetzt nicht gegen die Regeln verstoßen,
Sunfire so ein bisschen mit picquery ja also sind ja andere Regeln als bei dem Podcast beim Podcast geht konkret um die Inhalt bei dem App-Store Gezeiten,
auch teilweise um Inhalte ich kann jetzt die ganzen App-Store Regel nicht runter bieten die es an dieser Stelle vielleicht relevant sind die ändern sich ja auch haben sie über den mit der Zeit auch immer so ein bisschen geändert auf jeden Fall ist das ihre Position auf der Sie sich gerade befinden.
Aber sie hat die Fragen ok machen sie das vielleicht deshalb nicht,
um es nicht auch noch gleich diese Diskussion auch noch mit an der Backe zu haben was ihren Einfluss mit dem AppStore betrifft ja oder sehen Sie das tatsächlich anders
so oder so haben wir jetzt ebenso eine Debatte auf einmal an der Backe was ist denn jetzt hier wenn du heute ist komplett übertreiben
dürfen die denn überhaupt auf privaten Medienplattform ihr Unwesen einfach so weiter treiben wir es bisher.
Naja die andere Frage die man sich stellen kann ist dürfen diese privaten Medienplattformen überhaupt Leute rauswerfen also du.
Da müssen sie überhaupt jeden nehmen würde ich sagen.
Nee das ist sehr zwei zwei Seiten einer Medaille.
Die Frage die sie sich stellen lassen müssen und wo man ihnen viele Beispiele wahrscheinlich zeigen wird.
Es haben sie andere auch rausgeworfen wegen gleicher vergehen und da wird im Zweifelsfall werden sich jetzt viele Beispiele finden lassen wo die Leute nicht rausgeworfen haben.
Was bist du noch nicht.
Oder noch nicht und dann stellt sich eben die Frage haben diese.
Unternehmen das getan aus einer politischen Motivation heraus ist ist ja schon auch auffällig dass sie das so mehr oder weniger alle gleichzeitig machen,
also irgendwie binnen Stunden,
Apple fing an Facebook Spotify legt natürlich unter Umständen schon den Verdacht nahe dass die vielleicht mal kurz miteinander telefoniert haben.
Nee also da gibt es eine relativ solide Bericht Lage die das ausschließen.
Sag dir nur es liegt der Verdacht nahe.
Ja nee aber das war einfach nur dass ich das Apple ist gemacht hat waren die anderen einfach gerade da war.
Das mag sein aber die so die die.
Es ist natürlich schon irgendwie interessant dass sie das dass sie das tun und dass die anderen keine Argumente mehr hatten stimmt ja nicht denn von einer Plattform wurde er nicht geschmissen das ist Twitter,
er sagte ja Jack Dorsey dieser Twitter Gründer mehr oder weniger naja natürlich mag ich den nicht aber der versteht sich gegen unsere Regeln,
wir haben also gegen unsere Regeln hat er hier nicht verstoßen und deswegen können wir ihn hier nicht rauswerfen,
bei Donald Trump sagt er ja klar von bestimmter gegen unsere Regeln aber ist nun mal der Präsident ne also der hatte ja.
Steht aber in den Regeln bestimmt auch nicht so drin dass der Präsident gegen die Regeln verstoßen.
Nein nein natürlich nicht aber das also der dörflichen ausfällt ist die meisten hier mit zweierlei Maß und es ist sehr.
Sehr unschön.
Und ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich das wirklich gut finde dass dass das passiert ist.
Du musst ja auf einem fragen also wenn wenn wenn das nicht gegen eure Regeln verstößt seit vielleicht mit euren Regeln was nicht okay.
Das mag auch sein aber die Frage ist also die die haben jetzt die schmeißen Typen ist raus ja klar was wäre was ist das.
Am Ende ist es einfach nur Wasser auf seine Mühlen.
Du kannst dir die Seite jetzt angucken infowars.com das ist voll mit ladet jetzt noch unsere App runter bevor sie die auch noch zensieren.
Angriff auf die Meinungsfreiheit Angriff auf die Informationsfreiheit schwerer schwerer Schlag im Infokrieger also er wird kein.
Kein Mensch der das guck.
Und Ernst also keine Matches ernsthaft guckt wird sich jetzt sagen so, ja vielleicht vielleicht stimmt er vielleicht ist der Typ einfach echt ein bisschen durchgeknallt
und es ist vielleicht sinnvoll das irgendwie die Silicon Valley Milliardäre den jetzt irgendwie den Hahn abdrehen
ganz im Gegenteil die wär natürlich wieder sagen hier da sehen wir wieder diese ganzen Scheiß Liberalen
aus dem aus dem Silicon Valley die da irgendwie mit den Milliarden sitzen wenn ich hier auf meiner Farm fattore jetzt wollen sie den Alex Jones bekämpfen weil der sagt nämlich etwas was sie nicht hören wollen,
er hat ja schon immer gesagt dass dass es gegen ihn irgendwann vorgibt ähnlich sage ich mal wie,
Meta eine mit tausend Beinen hinkender Vergleich.
Viele Menschen bei den Vorwürfen gegen Julien Assange umgehend davon ausgegangen sind das die falsch sein müssen.
Und insofern ist es teilweise.
Also bin ich vorsichtig das jetzt hier eine eine besonders gute Aktion finden.
Haben Sie mal schauen wie wie Apple und so in Zukunft weitermachen ja wenn sich also.
Bei aller zu sehr ich die Werte Teile.
Sehe ich tatsächlich heute in letzter Zeit eine zunehmende Tendenz das.
Ja bagatellisiert Bares Verhalten sehr sehr ernst sehr hoch gejazzt wird ja und irgendwie kleinste.
Fehltritte in der EM im Geschmack sehr Leuten sehr übel genommen werden skandalisiert werden,
Menschen aus Positionen gedrängt werden in den USA insbesondere massiven Shitstorms ausgesetzt werden und ich bin mal gespannt wie lange das noch weitergeht bis bis diese.
Ist auch das irgend wenn man von seinen Kindern gefressen wird ne natürlich freue ich mich über jeden weniger der Alex Jones sieht ich würde mir aber wünschen dass das auf anderen Wegen passiert,
ja wie weiß ich auch nicht aber ich auf jeden Fall habe ich John Oliver Sendung darüber sehr viel mehr gefeiert.
Als jetzt irgendwie diesen Schritt der Plattform diese Typen da rauszuwerfen.
Na gut kann man sich fragen was mehr Wirkung hat in der Massephase ist natürlich schon Oliver
eine eine eine eine spitzen Adresse für den Nachrichten Kommission der Wii mit guter irgendwo
saxonische comedy was anfangen kann aber eben nicht unbedingt für so eine Masse die da halt einfach so rein meine viele Leute sind da auch einfach,
fehlgeleitet landen Ball bei welchen ganzen Schreihälsen im Netz und hier guck mal und so heute mal werden das auch in unseren Kommentaren,
oft schon gehabt na wenn wir hier so streitbare Themen haben
kann er doch wieder irgendeinen nee hier ist ja alles total anders guck mal hier das Video und dann sind es halt immer wieder so übliche Verdächtige Leute deren kompletter Lebensunterhalt wahrscheinlich einfach nur daraus besteht irgendwie einfach allem das Wort zu reden
immer noch irgendeine Gegenposition in im offensichtlichen auszumachen und da mit
fragilen Argumentationen um ein Gerüst aufzubauen und,
Leute wollen sich halt bestätigt sehen das hat irgendwie Prinzip auch schon den letzten Diskussionen hier in dieser Sendung.
Es ist einfach schwierig seine eigene Meinung.
Aufzugeben und es ist für manche Leute glaube ich auch irgendwo so ein bisschen so ein reward so irgendeine Meinung überhaupt auch mal zu haben,
und wenn es so gegen gegen alles was ihr alle anderen glauben,
geht dann kriegt das ja auch erstmal so einen Wert ich habe jetzt hier was besonderes und dann fühle ich mich dann auch noch bestätigt und hier guck mal da gibt's ja so viele Leute so und dann dann wird es einfach mal geglaubt weil man das einfach auch glauben will,
weil weil weil man wenn man das für sich dann auch überhaupt gar nicht mehr zulässt dass das alles nicht stimmt,
und dann werden halt auch Argumente sticht ignoriert und im Kleinen haben wir das auch.
Damit meine ich habe auch so meine Grundhaltung und so meine Meinung und so und wenn ich dann halt mal wieder feststelle
oh wow da habe ich mich aber dann doch mathematisch total verrannt dann merke ich auch einfach wie das so schmerzt weil ich da so ein Artikel lese wo drinsteht zurück Nethen
da hast du einfach mal komplett daneben gelegen und ist einfach mal ganz anders denke mal so zu oft passiert jetzt nicht,
aber auch ich bin davon nicht gefallen oder merke ich schon so ein bisschen so dieses,
wild will mein Geist das jetzt auch annehmen ja komme ich selber da auf einmal mit mit mit mir Glasfenster wichtige Übungen muss es auch mal machen dann kann auch mal auf Twitter sagen dass man nicht recht gehabt hat das dass.
Allein schon weil die Leute immer so überrascht sind wenn man ihn recht.
Dafür lohnt sich das schonmal.
Ja aber ist also würdest Du tatsächlich diese Aktion jetzt gut heißen die jetzt da von Apple Facebook Spotify vorgenommen wurde den Typen raus zu Kanten.
Und vor allem warum also ich heiße die schweren Herzens nicht gut.
Weil ich fürchte dass sie nichts bringt weil sie ich meinen bei YouTube kommen die Leute vielleicht wenigstens noch mal auf einen anderen Kanal wenn die wenn sie jetzt irgendwie auf infowars.com gehen müssen dann bleiben sie halt bei dem.
Und es ist eben Wasser auf seine Mühlen jetzt kann er sich da irgendwie als als bekämpft is Opfer stilisieren und sagt dann irgendwie Zwitter wahrscheinliche wie seine Sendung gehen und sagen soll
erst lachen sie über dich dann bekämpfen sie dich und dann hast du gewonnen endlich sind wir in Phase 2 so ne.
Ich bezahlte dass es wirksam ist zweitens ich glaube es ist alles.
Finde es nur dann gut tatsächlich wenn es wenn es wirklich wegen hate-speech ist.
Und sie sagen hier sind deine vergehen und sie vor allem dann auch muss man echt sagen.
Das Benennen und sagen Passau Freundchen wir haben ich dann er war er meint er mich dann ermahnt du hast hier gegen Muslime gehetzt das hier gegen Transgender Menschen gehört deine scheiß Zuschauer rennen ihr welche Pizzerien und ballern darum.
Die Frösche sind nicht mehr schwul als sie vorher waren und das ist auch gut so.
Und abgesehen davon werden die gar nicht schwul sondern Transgender so das ist nämlich tatsächlich die eklige.
Und jetzt reiß dich zusammen.
Also was den zweiten Teil betrifft da bin ich ganz bei dir also das ist generell ein Problem das.
Die Unternehmen zwar Regeln aufstellen die daneben weitreichende Folgen haben sie Verletzungen feststellen aber sie selten eben genau erklären,
Bismarck teilweise eben auch so sein dass es eben auch nicht so genau zu erklären ist und ist am Ende so eine Bauchentscheidung ist aber in gewisser Hinsicht sehe ich,
die Plattform an der Stelle auch in einer Bringschuld kannst,
was ist Jones selber betrifft und eine Opferrolle die sich daraus schließen kann weißt du.
Der ist eh die ganze Zeit dabei irgendwie sich in irgendeiner Opferrolle rein zu tun da braucht das jetzt eigentlich auch nicht
das was die dann da sozusagen durch durch dieses Jahr guckt mal stimmt ja alle sind ja alle gegen uns und das ist ja wiederum der Grund für was weiß ich dafür.
Da kannst du machen was du willst und die stricken,
dieses narrativ am laufenden Meter weiter ist vollkommen egal wo ist aber für mich ein positiven Effekt hat und weswegen ich,
ja dazu,
neige hier eher so das Wasser in die Richtung schwappen zusehen dass ich das gut finde ist es ist einfach auch wichtig dass solche großen Plattform auch eine Haltung zeigen und dass sie eben auch den anderen Leuten die irgendwie,
vielleicht auch nicht so genau wissen wo sie da stehen sollen auch einfach mit zeigen so, das geht zu weit das ist nicht mehr ok,
das ist das ist etwas was was einfach mit unserem mit Untergrund Verantwortung die wirken sie für dieses.
Für diese Gesellschaft oder wir räumen sie sich dann definieren der globale
nachricht mir ruhig von einer globalen Gesellschaft auch diese Verantwortung dass sie das ist eine solche haben und dir die auch auch auch mit Leben und damit sozusagen auch jenseits ihrer kapitalistischen verpflichtungen
auch einfach aufstehen gerade bei Apple ist es ja nun.
Letzten Jahren oft ein Thema gewesen ob es irgendwie,
die Rechte von Transfetten einen amerikanischen Unternehmen betrifft und ihr Verhältnis zur Umwelt dezentrales gibt ja viele Ebenen wo Unternehmen soetwas ausspielen können wo
woran sie auch gemessen werden und ich finde auch hier müssen sie das tun weil die Alternative heißt Lesens alles scheißegal,
wie das die Welt hier den Bach runter geht
geben unsere Regeln nicht her hauptsache ihr klickt und und die Kohle stimmt so und das sehe ich halt in dieser Maßnahme,
muss sagen Apple sind diejenigen die Erhaltung gezeigt haben und Facebook und YouTube mussten dann Haltung zeigen weil sie sonst.
So unter feuer gewesen wären das gar nicht.
Aber Marco arment started it der hat angefangen.
Ja ist kennen Sie also.
Baggerarbeit.
Facebook hat vorher auch schon mal diese temperatursperre gemacht also ich glaube das ist so ein.
Wie ein aos Entwickler barehanded.
Xilinx noch zu diesem Thema.
Ja warte mal Blätter Einsatz twitter ist jetzt echt noch mal ein anderes Ding Twitter finde ich an der Stelle auch wirklich mittlerweile in zunehmendem Maße wird die verlogen und scheiße,
ich kenne diesen Scheck persönlich nicht groß ich habe den jetzt nicht als Person ist bei der nicht besonders steht dem.
Inhalt auf Twitter.
Wenn ich mal das als ich habe kein ich habe keinen keinen keinen emotionalen betoch zudem ist mir ehrlich gesagt egal vielleicht hätten wir Ihre Podcasting irgendwie mal weiter machen soll.
Aber hast Du essen Podcast Plattform gestartet Vorsicht video is at war nicht so schlecht,
bitter ist schwierig Donald Trump hätten sie einen schon längst runterschmeißen müssen ja Präsident hin Präsident her,
das zeigt einfach dass dass das ihre ganzen Regeln einfach Scheißdreck sieht auch wenn sie in den letzten Jahren wenn wir jetzt mal vier Jahre zurückblicken gamergate etc.
Technisch auch eine Menge erreicht haben.
Ja also wenn du sie heute die betroffene von Gamer geht fragst gratistruhe gelesen mein so na ja nicht alles super aber es ist twitter ist als als Ort auf dem man sich aufhält im Vergleich zu damals ist extrem viel besser geht.
Woher ich glaube die Ausrede für Trump ist uns nicht der ist der Präsident sondern von often used where the value oder sowas also dass dadurch dass das was der twittert irgendwie.
Ja aber das finde ich wiederum extrem schwierig na weil.
Das ist halt das Ding ne und Umsätze Metaebene da auch noch mal zu betrachten das wird hier sicherlich in Kommentaren sonst auch gleich wieder aufkommen,
ja natürlich jetzt in USA ist immer diese gängige Definition,
na ja was wollt ihr denn das ist doch eine private Plattform die für die gelten doch jetzt nicht die Regeln wie es für irgendwas öffentliches Geld in USA immer schnell gesagt weil da gibt's irgendwie Aldi auch sonst überhaupt nichts öffentliches.
Zahlt man dann das Internet Interweb an sich und wird Wide Web und deine eigene Homepage und so da hast du das ja aber die Realität ist ja die neue Öffentlichkeit findet halt im privaten statt.
Öffentlichkeit ist auf YouTube ist auf
facebook hat irgendwie eine Instagram Realität ist älter als diese Plattform übernehmen ja in zunehmendem Maße die Rolle des Marktplatzes.
Leider aber es ist halt so ja so ist halt so gibt auch viele Gründe warum das so ist das sind so technische Zwänge die sich jetzt hier
entwickelt haben über die Jahre wo auch sagen muss da hat das freie webuntis das freie Internet in dem Sinne la auch nicht kommen sehen wie auch keine guten Antworten
gab es heute deswegen ist es halt einfach so und wird wahrscheinlich auch noch eine ganze Weile so bleiben aber dann heißt auch wiederum das eigentlich diese Plattform eben auch noch sehr viel mehr Verantwortung tragen als,
jetzt beiseite wischen können mit dieser Argumentation na ja was wollt ihr denn sind hier in kommerzielle Plattformen müsst ihr keinen reinlassen oder wir können dir rausschmeißen wenn wir wollen das ist natürlich so ein bisschen die die andere Seite der Medaille und das ist alles auch nicht,
einfach zu bewerten,
gelingt mir auch nicht da eine klare Position zu finden wie die Dinge denn nun eigentlich laufen sollten sie sagt nur als Jones rausschmeißen ist mein ganz guter move,
ihr könnt auch gerne noch ein bisschen mehr gegenhalten weil wenn da nicht gegen gehalten wird dann.
Okay dann dazu noch zwei Empfehlung erstens auf der Republica haben Richard gut hier und Markus Kompa einen Vortrag gehalten Anatomie eines
shit Tsunamis ihr erinnert euch vielleicht Richard Gutjahr
war der Journalist der vom Mossad nein das weißt du das war ein Journalist oder ist immer noch ein Tunnel ist der ganz ganz üblen Verschwörungstheorien und Anfeindungen ausgesetzt ist weil er
nach seinem Nizza Urlaub wo der,
wo dieser se kW dieser LKW Mord an der Strandpromenade stattfand wo er vor Ort war und Bericht erstattet hat eine Woche später eben in München war wo er lebte und dort bei diesem,
ihren Nazi der da um sich geschossen hat auch Bericht erstattet hat was dann irgendwie ein paar der Stochastik nicht ganz so mächtige Menschen veranlasst hat sehr sehr wirre und natürlich.
Antisemitische Theorien um ihn und sein Leben zu entwickeln von seinem Kampf dagegen hat er auf der Republica berichtet
nicht nur handwerklichen ganz besonders hervorragender Vortrag von den beiden also Markus Kompa sein Anwalt der ja auch bei uns schon mal,
in der Sendung zu Gast bei den Vortrag kann ich wärmstens empfehlen.
Zeiten will ich dann noch ganz kurz auf die Studie zu Atrazin hinweisen die wir verlinkt haben falls ihr mit dem gay Frog meme,
nicht vertraut seit haben wir hier die Studie vor ich rausgesucht die in der es prinzipiell darum geht das ist ein bestimmtes,
Pestizid heißen Jena die Pflanzen also Pflanzenschutzmittel oder ein Herbizid Moment was ist es genau.
Herbizid ein Herbizid das
zufolge hat tatsächlich wenn es ins Wasser gelangt in größeren Mengen bestimmte,
eine bestimmte Frosch Sorte hormonell beeinflusst für das bei denen das Testosteron
das Testosteron Östrogen Gleichgewicht irgendwie aus den Fugen gerät so dass die männlichen Frösche tatsächlich.
Kannst du denn da werden und das hat eben den lektions damals so geärgert,
weil er daraus natürlich abgeleitet hat das auch Menschen.
Unter diesem Phänomen leiden und dass dass das die,
ist die Regierung eben irgendwas ins Trinkwasser tut und deswegen renne ich erfahren was der ganzen schwulen Rum wird er sich das erklärt und das hat ihn sehr aufgeregt,
vielleicht können es ja alles verlegt mir auch noch ok kommen wir wieder zu ernsthaften Themen.
Wir erinnern uns letztes Jahr wurde er dann zunächst einmal final wieder wohnen Staatstrojaner er wieder,
eingeführte dir begleiten als CCC einen langjährigen Kampf dagegen.
Von der Anhörung wo ich da auch als Sachverständiger damals geladen war haben wir berichtet Ulf buermeyer war auch da unsere Stellungnahmen kann man lesen.
Jetzt.
Ist das Gesetz ja daneben in Kraft getreten durchgewunken worden und so weiter und jetzt gibt es eine Verfassungsbeschwerde dagegen angeführt von,
dem Verein digital courage aus Bielefeld der bei uns ja auch schon so lange Erwähnung findet wie er noch 5 UTS wahrscheinlich und.
Sie wenn sich alles hier haben diese Verfassungsbeschwerde yelp irgendwie eingereicht und haben dann noch,
argumentieren sehr ähnlich wie eben Ulf und ich auch in unseren Stellungnahmen und ich glaube wir waren die einzigen wenn ich ziemlich Rechte sind die einzigen beiden Gegner die anderen waren dafür.
Digital courage argumentiert dass hier natürlich ein wichtiges Rechtsgut,
verletzt wird nämlich bei der Online-Durchsuchung wo er der gesamte Computer durchsucht werden darf,
es muss geklärt werden weil ja das gesamte informationstechnische System überwacht wird und es quasi nicht möglich ist die Kommunikations Vorgänge zu überwachen für die das,
gesetzlich vorgesehen ist und natürlich die Frage mit den Sicherheitslücken irgendwie muss die Schadsoftware auf die Geräte kommen das heißt hier verletzt der Staat seine Schutzpflicht.
Und müsste in vielmehr sich darum bemühen das Grundrecht auf,
Integrität der informationstechnische Systeme aufrechtzuerhalten für natürlich dann auch wannacry und Notepad ja,
als Beispiele an für geheimdienstliche Versagen im horten von Schwachstellen,
und natürlich über allem steht der unverhältnismäßiger Eingriff in die Grundrechte sie haben dazu noch eine selbstgemachte Online-Petition auf ihrer Webseite wo man jetzt irgendwie mit klicken soll,
um auf 25000 Unterschrift zu kommen ich halte das für keine besonders kluge Idee sowas zu tun weil,
jetzt muss man eben diese selbstgemachte Online-Petition sich der anschauen die natürlich keine.
Der ist sowieso keine Relevanz hat und noch dazu eben jetzt irgendwie mal in die,
dadurch dass Sie da auch nicht die große Bandbreite hat eben irgendwie.
Auch überhaupt erstmal auf ihre Zahlen kommen muss und dann natürlich auch noch mit dem Spendenformular direkt verbunden wurde,
andererseits finde ich Zeit auch sehr unschön wenn wenn sowas dann eben noch nicht mal seine 25000 erreicht also strategisch unklug das zu tun aber jetzt müssen wir da leider mal mit ziehen um diese Verfassungsbeschwerde eben auch nicht irgendwie.
Da als unwichtig in der Luft hängen zu lassen.
Nächstes Mal wäre es gut dass ohne zu machen und coole ohne so eine Petition und cooles dann digital courage und die Anwälte dass sie sich da weiterhin engagieren das war zu hoffen
das ist da losgeht und andere Organisationen tun das natürlich auch und werden von uns daneben ansprechender Stelle,
gewürdigt wichtig diesen Kampf eben dann auch vor den Gerichten weiterzuführen das ist ja so ein bisschen das wo mein Engagement eben.
Aufgrund meiner bildungsfernen Sozialisation,
endet da ich aber ein Jurastudium von meinen Eltern ja untersagt wurde erhalten erzählt.
Ich wollte Jura studieren und ich habe mich auch für Jura bevor mich hatte und Studienplatz in Dior und.
Dann haben meine Eltern gesagt nee nee mach mal Psychologie und als ich mit Psychologie fertig habe ich gesagt jetzt,
jetzt schreibe ich mich für Jura ein weil ich ja auch forensische Psychiatrie und so gemacht hatte also bei so ein bisschen den rechtlichen Bereich,
und dann haben wir Eltern gesagt so pass auf du kannst alles machen jedes andere schon mal gesagt zu diesen Juristen das werden entweder Langweile oder a********** und da fahren wir uns nicht die ganze Mühe mit dir gegeben,
alles andere Katze machen aber das nicht.
Meine Eltern haben teilweise auch Jura belegt was ich dazu ja er gewinnt.
Übersandte deine Haltung.
Jamaika.
Ja doch das irgendwie also ich hatte immer Jahre voll mein Eltern erzählt dass ich da irgendwie der ständig in ihren zum Theater eine oder drinnen Museum in der Schlange und
sprach dann irgendwie darüber dass ich irgendwie meinen Studentenausweis irgendwie abgelaufen ist oder so und dann sprach einmal hinter mir mich an und
wie sich ihr wie mit Paragraph auf mein Vergehen gerade hin dass ich mir hier eine Leistung erschleichen mit dem gefälschten Studierendenausweis derevi sowas Saranda das habe ich meine Eltern damals erzählt mir sagte meine Mutter so weißt du doch dieser Mann damals in Köln im Museum willst du dieser Mann werden.
Hast das Gefühl dass sie dich vor der etwas bewahrt haben oder wurde die wo die dir eine große Chance hätte was aus dir werden können.
Ich glaube ich wär ein guter Anwalt geworden ich glaube echt ich bin guter Anwalt geworden
aber ich glaube auch dass ich also ich merke das ja also gerichtliche Auseinandersetzung und so sind auch nicht gut für mein Herz
also so überall über irgendwie schreiende Ungerechtigkeiten und so kann ich mich ja dann doch längere Zeit aufregen insofern weiß ich nicht ob ich lange,
Anwalt geblieben wäre oder daneben früh,
mit Herzkasper so am im Gerichtssaal seid ihr wieder dort wäre wäre insofern jetzt bin ich hier ich kann nicht anders.
Ich konnte Dich einfach ich würde da gehindert.
Der kann ich mich schon wieder aufregen hier Bundesgerichtshof Urteil ne meine Güte.
Dagas aber eine eine Schülerin an einer Gesamtschule in Nordrhein-Westfalen.
Die irgendwie ein Referat gemacht hat und in diesem Referat hat sie ein Foto der Stadt Cordoba verwendet.
Und hat er unter das Foto noch weil ihr de valliere wenn dir eine artige Schülerin ist noch ein Link zur Quelle gemacht,
da und jetzt dann ging die Lehrer zur hin und haben dieses Referat wurde daneben auf der das fertige Referat Samtpfote und Link zu der Quelle,
wurde dann auf der Schule Internetseite der Schule eingestellt.
Und der Fotograf des Bildes hat Dirk renckhoff war damit nicht einverstanden dass hier ja seine Urheberrechte in besonderem Maße verletzt werden und hat dann die Stadt und das Land,
NRW verklagt was den denn ein viele dass dieses Gesamtschüler rennen Referat geziert wird von seinem Bild mit mit Link zur Quelle,
ohne dass das Bildungssystem in da den notwendigen Tantiemen zur Unterstützung seiner.
Reisen in spanische Städte bezahlt und jetzt wurde.
Jetzt stellte sich also die Frage ob.
Ob man hier also einerseits würde sich natürlich eigentlich die Frage stellen ob man sagt ja komm.
Bitte dich einfach mal Schüler Schüler sein lassen.
Kinkerlitzchen Fair-Use deine Rechte sind in keinem messbaren Maße
beschnitten worden es gibt keinen messbaren finanziellen Nachteil der dir entstanden ist dadurch dass hier irgendwo 11 Schülerinnen Referat liegt dieses ganze Ding ging irgendwie an den an den,
ging hoch bis zum BGH und der BGH hat das dann dem AGH gegeben weil er fragen wollte ob der Link auf die Quelle,
auch bei einem neu hochgeladene Bild eine zulässige Nutzung Nutzung da sein könnte weil es gab nämlich schon einäugiger Urteil,
Einbettung von anderswo gehosteten Inhalt also das Bild bleibt an seiner Quelle ich schreibe aber einfach nur imgsrc gleich und
finde das in meiner eigenen Seite ein so und jetzt sagt der IGH dazu dadurch dass das Bild aber separat hochgeladen wurde.
Das macht den entscheiden Unterschied hätte die Schule,
in diesem ich weiß nicht welchen Format das jetzt hochgeladen war wahrscheinlich PDF oder was auch immer hätten sie dort das Bild von fern eingebettet mit Link dann wäre das offen bei ihr wie eine andere Situation gewesen als wenn sie dahin
selber noch einmal hochladen und D-Link dadrunter schreiben.
Der OGH hat aber anerkannt das Hyperlinks zum Guten funktionierendes Internetbeitrag so und jetzt haben sie der Generalanwalt an dem OGH hat natürlich in seinem Schlussantrag genau das Gegenteil gesagt hat gesagt,
hier ist der nicht-kommerzielle Nutzung hier ist ein ganz klarer Link zur Originalquelle.
Das Bild hat eine absolut untergeordnete Bedeutung für das Gesamtwerk des Referates der junge Dame und,
es gab auch keine Hinweise auf der auf der Seite ist Fotograf ist das in irgendeiner Form Nutzungseinschränkung für dieses Bild bestehenden sagte Generalanwalt,
die Nutzung der Schule als rechtmäßig einzustufen der ögh geht aber in keiner Form überhaupt auf die Empfehlung des Generalanwalts ein sondern,
verdonnert hier die Schule.
Und sagt jegliche grundsätzlich jede Nutzung ohne Zustimmung des Rechteinhabers ist nicht illegal,
es sei denn es gibt zwei Ausnahmen Zitatrecht oder Satire aber da sie das Foto nicht zitiert und Satie reard hat,
hat hier eben die die Schule und die Schülerin gegen den Fotografen verloren.
Das war jetzt eine Aussage des BGH ok also der Generalanwalt okay gut.
Ja das eine neue GH gegeben Unterbezug und jetzt kam das sot vorbeugehaft zurück ja.
Okay das ist ja sehr ungewöhnliches hat mir ja auch schon paar mal das wieder Generalanwalt EuGH was vorschlägt das DGH sich selber dagegen wendet und was anderes beschließt das ist halt hier wenn er wieder mal einer dieser seltenen Fälle und ja.
Copyrighted sich mal wieder durch und.
Also seid einfach nur.
Dieser Mangel an Verjus ist einfach ein Problem ist dass wir da einfach immer noch nicht auch nur im Ansatz irgendwas haben wo man zumindest mal ich meine was ist denn jetzt hier eigentlich,
die Konsequenz jetzt für für für die Stadt also jetzt kriegt der Fotograf da eine Entschädigung oder was.
Ich komme jetzt vermutlich noch nicht einmal das also ich oder vielleicht auch schon vielleicht kann er irgendwelche so genau kenne ich mich da leider mit diesem urheberrechtlich aus ne aber es ist irgendwie,
erstmal diese Grundsatzentscheidungen beendet zum Original gibt's ja immer nur so Sachen zur Prüfung die dann irgendwie wieder zurück komme dann wird er jetzt irgendwie in irgendeiner Form beurteilt werden.
Hör mal was im Herbst in Europa im alten Parlament abgeht vielleicht tut sich da.
Leonardo wo schreibt dazu abschließend der ögh spielt da mit den Ball zurück an den europäischen Gesetzgeber der das Urheberrecht alltagstauglicher gestalten müsste z.b. mit Alcatel Regelung.
Aber in den aktuellen Reformvorschläge finden wir sowas ja nicht Julia Rehder kann davon ein Lied singen.
Dann haben wir in vielen Bundesländern Debatten um die Polizeigesetze wir erinnern uns an Bayern,
wir erinnern uns an NRW jetzt auch in Niedersachsen Niedersachsen hat immerhin gleich drei Tage für Anhörung angesetzte zum neuen
Polizeigesetz der war dann z.b. die Datenschutzbeauftragte Barbara Thiel die sagt unter dem Deckmantel den internationalen Terrorismus zu bekämpfen beschneiden die vorgeschlagen,
bis zur Unkenntlichkeit,
es ist nicht einmal ansatzweise erkennbar Warum derartige Verschärfungen erforderlich sind was von was für Verschärfung reden wir naja elektronische Fußfessel,
und Staatstrojaner dann bodycams im Free recording Modus muss man sich vorstellen BZ 30 Sekunden Cash was heißt die Kamera ist immer an,
und wenn löscht aber qualso erhält immer nur 30 Sekunden in ihrem Speicher und wenn man dann drauf drückt dann nimmt sie die letzten 30 Sekunden mit rein.
Haben sie das quasi vorher geschehen ist noch noch mit zu sehen ist allgemeine Videoüberwachung soll zukünftig bei jeder infrage kommenden Straftat,
geben bzw zulässig sein eine Herausgabepflicht von Bild und Tonträgern oh was könnte sich denn dahinter verbergen bis bei einer bis bei einer Demonstration.
Und und gib Handy.
Ja gib Andy und verdeckte akustische und optische Bespitzelung im öffentlichen Raum ohne dass die Betroffenen nachher darüber informiert werden müssen also auch wieder ihre Hardcore was einmal das komplette Wunschprogramm.
Loser wie also die Stasi rotiert im Grab und sagt warum haben wir das nicht.
Im Bayerischen Polizeirecht erinnern wir uns um die an die drohende Gefahr haben wir uns damals lange drüber unterhalten was für eine drohende Gefahr in Niedersachsen ist das die dringende Gefahr also man könnte sagen,
Grund ist jetzt dringend.
Die ausreicht als Voraussetzung für präventive Telekommunikationsüberwachung,
präventive Telekommunikationsüberwachung mir auch wirklich irgendwie es bleibt da wirklich amüsant der Chaos Computer Club hat er auch eine Stellungnahme eingebaut haben wir verlinkt.
Und es gibt eine,
Webseite dazu jetzt bin ich auch wieder verwundert dass die nicht in den scheunert schon drin ist das ist glaube ich die.
NPG.
Notebook.de genau das notebook Bündnis ruft nämlich zu Demonstrationen das muss auch noch in unsere Termine nehmen wir das gleich in die in den in die Termine mit auf also notebook.de,
da gibt es da sammelt sich der Protest und die die die Gegenwehr,
gegen diese Seite und der Aufruf erging diese gegen dieses Gesetzesentwurf und der Aufruf zum 89.
Zur Großdemonstration in Hannover den wir gleich auch noch mal in den Termin.
Ich so perfekte akustische und optische Bespitzelung lesen.
Habe ich immer wieder für soll ich sagen also,
wenn man so öffentliche Diskussionen über die Notwendigkeit von Überwachungsmaßnahmen verfolgt ne bis zu Plastikkarten mit man hätte ja nichts zu verbergen jetzt drastisch Unsinn ist.
Hat jeder was zu verbergen und ist auch überhaupt nicht die Frage ob man was zu verbergen hat es geht Dich doch immer mal was zu verbergen hat,
und deswegen darf man komplett ausgeräumt werden sonst muss einfach ein begründetes belegtes,
relevantes Interesse bestehen irgendjemand zu überwachen und dann macht man das und man überwacht nicht einfach mal alle so früher war das ja auch immer schon so ein Thema.
Und früher,
hat man dann auch die Behörden die Politiker die politischen Ideenträger auch noch vergleichsweise einfach wieder zurückgedrängt bekommen.
Warum weil die Sachen auch immer scheiße teuer waren.
Und am Ende sozusagen so dieser Überwachungswahn der immer angeprangert wurde meist deshalb nicht so ausgelebt werden konnte weil es dafür einfach diese Budgets,
nicht ab oder der ganze Zeugs das ganze Zeug viel zu klobig und technisch zu kompliziert war es sind aber man muss aber an der Stelle noch mal betonen,
wir leben da jetzt wirklich in einer anderen Zeit Geräte die eine akustische Überwachung machen sind Daumennagel groß
da haben genug Akku movie tagelang irgendwo rumzuliegen etc und können das irgendwie alles per LTE in die Welt tragen
das ist
alles überhaupt gar keinen Spaß mehr und mittlerweile gibt es allein schon so einen riesigen privaten Markt von privaten Überwachungsmaßnahmen damit die Leute irgendwie ihre Eigenheimer absichern können für die drohende Zombieapokalypse,
die Technik ist da sie wird gebaut ist basna vorhanden und in dem Moment wo man jetzt solche Gesetze ziehen lässt ja ist da einfach,
Tür und Tor geöffnet einfach auch wirklich diese massenhafte Überwachung dentate dich endlich auch wirklich herzustellen weil so billig.
Kleiner Exkurs also wie billig das tatsächlich ist wenn wurde mir bei der Lektüre eines Artikels von von Anna biselli gewahr die ja jetzt aktuell,
bei Vice Motherboard schreibt ist er vor einigen Monaten darüber gewechselt ob sie macht eine,
mutterschutzvertretung oder so also unseren Hörerinnen und Hörern bekannt als investigativjournalist in bei Netflix auch regelmäßig hier zu Gast gewesen.
Kritik 256 ganz wunderbar in Stellung gebracht und unserem jeopardy.
Jeopardy und auch natürlich beim Podcast technische Aufklärung immer dabei gewesen also,
kannst du gar keine Unbekannte so setzt sich mit dem mit der Eber mit den Kosten
der gesichtserkennungs Probelauf Wettläufe da am S-Bahnhof Südkreuz in Berlin auseinander und,
diese Kosten sind auch lächerlich gering das war mir gar nicht klar die miete
halbes Jahr Miete für diese Gesicht Erkennungssysteme waren ursprünglich 60000 € einkalkuliert dann wurde das würde die Experimentierphase um halbes Jahr verlängert am Ende
kosteten die drei verschiedenen ausprobierten Systeme 100 und 4000 € für ein halbes Jahr des Herrn Klecks.
Finde ich Hilfe irgendwie drei verschiedene Gesichtserkennung Videosysteme miete ok in der Wendy kauft sind die natürlich einmal teurer als funktionieren aber länger.
Und dann kam noch bisher unbekannte Ausgaben von 158 000 Euro dazu also insgesamt haben wir ja doch eine über eine Viertelmillion da verballert aber,
die Preise sind wirklich relativ niedrig das Referenzsystem also dieses Vergleichs System was über die Leute diese
diese Transponder getragen haben das hat 72
1000 gekostet 200800 das heißt eben ein System womit du einfach nur guckst ob bestimmte Transponder zustimmt Zeiten da sind weil es eben spezifisch für diesen Fall angesetzt wurde kostet fast soviel wie dreigesicht Erkennungssystem in dem gleichen Zeitraum
na und die Bodenmarkierungen wo drauf stand hier Achtung.
Scheiße mit Kameras ja 71700 Euro da siehst du mal was diese ganzen aluhüte uns kosten Tim,
aber also krass ist natürlich nett diese diese Preise mal zum Vergleich um das um den Punkte zu untermauern wie wie unglaublich billig,
diese voll Überwachung eben tatsächlich geworden ist da das ist na so ein sehr entscheidend.
Kommen wir nun zum Hack sport.sk Pocking Angriffe auf die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen hoffentlich hat er niemand aus unseren Kommentaren,
hinter gesteckt vor allem nicht vor allem bitte nicht Dimitri.
Denn wie es immer so ist bei Hecking das muss der Russe gewesen sein,
die Angriffe werden zugeschrieben der russischen Hackergruppe cento an die vom Verfassungsschutz auch beschuldigt wird oder anderen die Sabotage in der Ukraine vorgenommen zu haben
klassisches Vorgehen hier offenbar mit mit fishing.
Und beim das ZDF hat dann sogar bekannt gegeben dass bei ihnen 10 Computer betroffen waren.
Zu Fragen der attribution kann ich hier die immer keine Stellung nehmen ich kann nur sagen dass es sehr schwer möglich sowas zu attribuieren aber,
um zu sagen ob die attribution hier gut oder schlecht ist er hätte ich selber mal einen sich darin haben müssen die wir natürlich wieder nicht haben.
Mitered Ruby attribuieren meinte Dinos sagen wer es war.
Das ein Fremdwort.
Auf jeden Fall jetzt hier einfach.
Ok
Der Spiegel hat außerdem berichtet dass bei dieser angeführte unter anderem auch das Labor betroffen gewesen sein,
könnte das die Diana die chemische Analyse in diesem Skript Fall gemacht hat die also das nowitschok.
Danach gewiesen haben oder geprüft haben oder versucht haben herauszufinden wo dieses nowitschok her kam die das Labor namens Spiez hat gesagt er sei der Angriff bekannt und,
es wurde da irgendwie ein Dokument zu einem vom Labor organisierten Workshop verwendet also die kriegen irgendwie.
Da da ist auf jeden Fall irgendwie wieder da rappelts im Karton viel spannender finde ich aber.
Den hacking Angriff den MSC international berichtet und zwar im Juni 2018 hat ein quasi ein Amnesty International staff member eine,
dort eingestellte Person eine whatsapp-nachricht bekommen mit so einem clickbait der irgendwas mit Saudi-Arabien.
ADAC auch saudi-arabische Menschenrechtsverletzungen bezog und dann wurde das untersucht bei Amnesty International sind ja gute Leute angestellt inzwischen.
Die also dann die nachricht analysiert haben den Link darin und dann irgendwie die Schadsoftware die sich dahinter verbirgt und Verbindung zu ihr wie über 600 Domainnamens,
die wiederum teilweise Verbindung zu tun.
Der NSA Gruppe hatten also die NSA Group ist wenn ich mich nicht täusche ein israelisches Unternehmen zur die eben auch Smartphone Trojaner herstellen für den staatlichen Gebrauch
den sogenannten Pegasus Trojaner wir hatten darüber auch schon Vorträge auf dem Kongress sowohl vom citizenlab als auch von.
Wer was denn noch dieses kommerzielle Unternehmen vermehrt gerade nicht eine auch zwei Vorträge zu zu Pegasus auf dem Kongress.
Und hier sieht man mal wieder wie diese Schulden Staatstrojaner Hersteller eben auch mit allen Staaten zusammenarbeiten und so einer der Staaten die auch ganz besonders für ihre Demokratie bekannt sind ist ja Saudi Arabien,
da ist jetzt irgendwie in diesem Jahr Frauen das Autofahren jetzt erlaubt haben also auch da wirklich eine radikale Demokratisierung die da stattfindet.
Das wäre gut ne.
Jetzt wird jetzt mit staatstrojanern gegen Amnesty International so und dann natürlich hier die nSo group.
Da willst du das jetzt schlecht reden dass die Frauen Autofahren dürfen.
Nee ich würde aber gerne schlecht reden dass du mit mit staatstrojanern gegen Amnesty International Angestellte vorgehst ja und das Kabel von Saudi-Arabien erwarte ich ja nichts anderes aber diese Staatstrojaner Hersteller.
Fühl dich also so gerne als die die die Retter des des guten Geschmacks und der der Demokratie und der Menschenwürde und es Kampf gegen den Terrorismus und ich meine klar aus saudi-arabischer Perspektive sind MST natürlich
Terroristen und insofern kann man da wahrscheinlich der NS Augen keinen,
Vorwurf machen aber es zeigt ihm auch wieder mit welchen Unternehmen man sich da einlässt wenn man so einer scheiße an.
Gut wir sagen das bringt uns jetzt zu dem Termin.
So was geht ab im August Seiten wir z.b. am 16.08 das sind Donnerstag glaube ich 2018 dich Linus da fällst du ein ins Millerntor.
Forza St. pauli.
Hahaha also.
Ehrlich bin ich auch ja also ich fange dann an nach dem heutigen 2 zu 0 kann ich ja dann direkt nicht halt nur einen Vortrag.
Gardine stehst du den Kader vor allerdings nur in den Fan räumen
da gibt's ja ganz netter das ist ja beim FC St. pauli ist das ja ganz Neisser ist im Stadion gibt es einen Bereich der explizit nur für die Fans zur Verfügung steht fanräume
was erzählst du da.
Herüber also im Prinzip über was dürfen Ermittlungsbehörden was machen sie tatsächlich welche Daten fallen an also im Prinzip so ein bisschen das kleine Daten Einmaleins für den engagierten Fußballfan.
Fußballfan ok nicht nur für Fußballfans aber vielleicht schon mit dem Folk.
Sei nicht für alle gleich ne ob wir auf jetzt.
Dritte Halbzeit oder dem oder den gleichen Maßnahmen ausgesetzt.
Ja was gibt's noch dann haben wir im Ende August also am 31. August bis 2. September gibt's wieder ein Hacker Camp habe ich noch gar nicht drüber gesprochen das
electromagnetic field nach wie vor der schönste Name der je für eine Hacker Veranstaltung gewählt wurde ich war da beim letzten Mal schon weg diesmal wieder hinfahren,
und warum erwähnen wir das weil es mal erwähnt werden sollte ist leider schon offiziell ausverkauft
sollte allerdings unter unseren hören jemand sein der noch dringend Ticket sucht könnten wir da unter Umständen behilflich sein dann schreibt er uns einfach eine Mail,
das ganze findet statt in England im Herford Scheer in der Nähe von led.
Deutscher ledbury beast nocaster Tierpark da ist das.
Ob man da so redet weiß ich so ganz genau also ist nur Kater ist und lünenschloss und da gibt's dann so einen schönen Park und Campingplatz und Pipapo hört euch alles anschauen auf ihrem 11 cam.org falls ihr da seid.
Ich halte einen Vortrag ich halt auch mal Vortrag ja sowas hätte ich.
Hat noch jemand dran geändert das Bits und Bäume
findet ihr erst im November statt aber der Koffer papers geht nur noch bis zum 19. August und wichtig ist dass ich auch assemblies bitte indem CFP anmelden damit die es Family area
GEW sortiert werden kann.
Was sind Bits und Bäume.
Bitte Bäumer ist die Veranstaltung am 17 und 18 November in der
TU-Berlin die sich darum bemüht die verschiedenen Gesellschaftsveränderung verändernden Bewegungen die teilweise in Deutschland ebenso getrennt voneinander gewachsen sind ein bisschen zu verheiraten also alles was um nachhaltig
bemühtes
ob es jetzt darum geht die Macht von Konzernen einzudämmen die Natur zu schützen demokratische Teilhabe auszuweiten oder eben auch die Digitalisierung menschengerecht zu gestalten allem,
solche Organisationen und Gruppen werden eingeladen sich da unter dem,
Themenfeld der Nachhaltigkeit auf zu begegnen auszutauschen und da ist besonderer Wunsch der Veranstalterin und Veranstalter dass ebendiese es Family area möglichst,
der breit aufgestellt ist und da seid Ihr also eingeladen euch zu informieren und am CFP zu beteiligen.
Genau findet in Berlin statt EW ohne Musik macht das gar keinen Spaß.
Ja 7 Uhr.
Müssen wir jetzt müssen wir so ne Musik weiter mal oder wenn wir fahren wir zum zweiten Teil der Termine.
Termine.
So da gibst du dich dann noch.
Alles nur noch 1 oder.
Mittweida Ende Ende August bis fast Mitte September 29.08 1909 findet der alles allen Kongress Konvoi statt.
Was ist das denn jetzt schon wieder.
Man sieht diese Veranstaltung wurde auf einem Plenum benannt weil in einer Diktatur wärst du dir auf so einem
Narben gekommen man könnte sagen der alles einen Kongress Konvoi ist der Lückenfüller bzw die Nachfolgeorganisation für den Weltkongress der hedonistischen internationale der in diesem Jahr nicht stattfindet.
Die internistische internationale hat sich ebenfalls auf ein Plenum entschieden dieses Jahr keinen Weltkongress auszurichten und deswegen gibt es jetzt von sympathisieren denn.
Aus Hamburg Berlin und unterschiedlichen Städten nun den,
man könnte sagen den WeltCon vor den den Welt Konvoi der hedonistischen internationale hier als alles einen Kongress Konvoi betitelt der unter dem Motto stattfindet raus aus der Blase rein in den Schaum,
sehr schön das wurde wahrscheinlich nicht auf einem den unbesetzt weil das ist viel zu kernig,
ich habe nichts gegen Zehner ich gehe nur die hin.
Subnautica Grenzkontrolle.
Jawa.
Also der Kongress Konvoi startet unter anderem in Berlin und Hamburg.
Und dann geht's in das Basislager in Friedland bei Schwichtenberg um von dort aus mit mehreren autonom Konvois wieder in das weite um Land zu ziehen
und am zweiten Woche ist zweiten Wochenende ist es dann in Neubrandenburg wo die Zelte aufgeschlagen werden also es geht ein bisschen darum
die Workshops Vorträge Diskussionen Musik und Performance ist ein bisschen von der Veranstaltung auch wegzutragen,
und eben hier in in in brandenburgische Hinterland mit
einer aufgeschlossenen fröhlichen Botschaft mit Musik mit Freude am Leben und Lust am Widerstand zu gehen und eben mit diversen Menschen die für eine freie Gesellschaft
kämpfen
hier sich zu vernetzen und echte Alternativen aufzuzeigen ganze muss natürlich auch finanziert werden deswegen ist der Vorverkauf jetzt gestartet es gibt viele Möglichkeiten und Notwendigkeiten sich einzubringen,
unter hkk 18. Org seid ihr herzlich eingeladen an diesem alles allen Kongress Konvoi teilzunehmen.
Und wie schon erwähnt haben wir dann noch die Großdemo in Hannover gegen das hier schon ausführlich diskutiert die niedersächsische Polizeigesetz am 8. September,
startet in Hannover das Nervus startet hier.
Am Ernst-August-Platz.
Starte distale Ende.
Ja es hat laments Ausfall.
Starte dam Ernst-August-Platz mit dem Schwanz.
Ist das der mit dem mit dem Schwanz.
Ja man trifft sich da unterm Schwanz aber ich glaube die Demo trifft sich dann nicht unterm Schwanz wegen medicali richtig an.
Das ist gar nicht am Hauptbahnhof doch das ist aber auch das ist doch da wo steht die EM wie dem Führer sein treues Volk oder.
Ja erst August es ist auf dem Pferd und man trifft sich unter dem Schwanz des Pferdes ist wegen Hals unterm Schwanz dem Landesvater sein treues Volk steh niedersächsische gtt.
Dieter wirklich dem Führer sein treues Volk Albertina dem Landesvater sein treues Volk trifft sich am 8.9 am Ernst August.
Genau so siehts aus und das stand irgendwie einmal um die City herum.
Und das endet dann irgendwo am müsste das doch alles kennen ja Marstall oder was kramerstraße wie auch immer.
An der Markthalle.
Anna Markthalle genau da ist die Abschlusskundgebung da.
Könnte auf jeden Fall mal hingehen gibt ja sonst nicht so viel zu tun in Hannover ich lobe an dieser Stelle die Gruppe non pg für das geile Logo.
Niedersachsen verdächtig.
Bist du bist ja dieses noch mal genau einschaltet ist das niedersächsische also das ist wirklich super nice genau.
Trojaner drauf gebaut kleines Trojanisches Pferd sehr schön sei gelobt der Vater fein gemacht.
So wir müssen es auch ganz fein gemacht und hier mal wieder so ein zwei stunden Brett hingelegt ja doch doch ich bin auch zufrieden mit mir ich bin auch zufrieden mit.
Ich bin zufrieden mit mir mit dir nicht ganz so nein ich bin zufrieden mit der Sendung trink noch ein bisschen Mathe.
Ja ich denke auch dass Kürbisse abliefern.
Wo wir dabei sind.
Die peinlichen stellen schnell mal raus.
Das jetzt gesagt er ist zwei stunden lange fällt Leute sagen wir auf einmal 20 Minuten Podcast kriegen.
Wir könnten an dieser Stelle noch danken wie immer aber sonst irgendwas loszuwerden.
Gerade nicht so.
Also ich danke das jetzt ein bisschen länger.
Ich danke Bernd zu wiederholten Male Jens Stephan.
Rene Tarifa nicht sehr gefreut weil ich ja hier immer am Ende so eine so eine lange Liste Männernamen verlesen muss also ich finde eigentlich dass ich mehr Zuwendung von Frauen verdient hätte.
Noch.
Finde es reicht schon.
Stephan einer unbekannten Person die wenn sie ändern jetzt hier nicht hört sich sehr gerne kurz bei mir melden mag.
Markus Matthias Björn Andreas Philipp,
Clemens und Toni gesagt unbekannte Person wenn ihr wenn ihr euch ihr nicht hört schreib mir mal ganz kurz über das Kontaktformular manchmal gibt's da komische,
Dinge dass ich die Grußbotschaft nicht Kriege oder so.
Genau und all die Leute die sich jetzt im Rahmen der tausendundeins Daueraufträge aufgerafft haben die kriege ich gar nicht alle zusammen geschrieben,
darf ich dazu zu späteren Zeitpunkt noch mal Wasserstandsmeldungen aber auch an der Stelle vielen Dank schon mal für alle die sich hier einbringen.
Und zu sagen damit der morgen auch ausreichend lange.
Also Leute verlassen euch wieder Liebe und.
Zurück an der Arbeit.
Heißt es auch das nächste mal wenn ihr uns sagen wird guten Morgen Dino.
Und gute Nacht Tim.